Welcome back!
Thank you very much!
Oh, sorry for the delay.
I...
Look, I'm jumping.
Oh!
I didn't do that.
That's not me.
I am jumping though.
Look at me go.
I don't know why he's stopping.
Welcome everybody to Atlantis no nazo.
Oh, I got it.
Nice.
He's acting on his own, honestly.
I'm surprised he's still alive.
Look at him go.
How does the rage meter work?
Go!
Jump!
It just happens.
You know?
Right now it's at 0% rage.
0% rage.
Everybody.
We're good.
Everything is calm.
We're all good.
Thanks for the gift, Petty!
If you are unaware of this game, it is just a notoriously difficult platformer like old from Famicom era game.
It's Atlantis no nazo.
I don't even know what to say.
Sorry, my brain is so out of sorts today.
One month!
Thank you guys!
Wait.
Happy one month.
Are these like one months from before I graduated or...
It's weird saying that.
Or has it been a month since I opened up memberships?
I can't.
It's been one month since you opened up?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Okay, I'm really confused because memberships are showing up.
Okay, hold on.
Let me ask...
Let me check real quick for Streamlabs.
I checked last night, but nothing was weird.
Um...
But yeah, so I'm gonna do my best with this game.
There's 99 levels.
There's 90...
Wait, what is this?
Interesting.
Um, there's 99 levels.
So I'm gonna try and clear everything.
I'm gonna do my best.
Excited for Kamige.
Streamlabs test.
Well, I think there were some gifted so it might be a little...
Sorry, my brain is really today.
I'm so sorry.
Uh...
Why did...
What is going on?
Wait...
Eh?
I think...
I think Streamlabs changed.
Eh?
Huh?
Okay, that worked, but...
That worked.
Eh?
I'm confused.
Huh?
They changed the whole side.
I don't understand it anymore.
Wait, where do I...
Where's my custom ones?
Oh no...
Wait...
Eh?
Oh, eh?
Oh, tip variation.
Eh?
Worked!
Yubi!
Okay, that worked.
Okay, sorry guys for that little delay.
Some of these things I can't test.
Unless I'm on stream, right?
So...
The CPU...
CPU in the demo mode is pretty bad.
Now, I'm not gonna look... I'm not gonna be as bad as this guy at all.
So, all you can do... Here, I'll show you guys.
Let's...
Let's start.
Oh my gosh.
First zone mystery adventure start.
Okay, this is just to show you guys how the game works.
So you can throw bombs.
You have to avoid the poop.
And you can duck.
Oh!
And you can jump.
And that's it.
When you jump, you can't... Oh my gosh.
You can't move while you're jumping.
It can make things quite difficult.
Point!
Watch out for the poop.
But um...
Maybe I could jump over those guys.
Treasure!
And we're here to discover the mystery of Atlantis.
What?
Oh my gosh.
I didn't see that guy!
The mystery of Atlantis.
Look out!
I'm gonna keep going this way.
Wait, how do I...
Oh my gosh.
Don't poop on me.
Uh...
Up?
No.
Um...
Hold on.
Maybe bomb it?
Bomb?
Okay...
You have to throw a bomb at the door.
Oh, I tried!
Let's try this way.
No worries.
We have seven... five lives.
We have five lives, everybody.
It's all good.
Oh my gosh.
That was so close.
Treasure!
Yeah!
Okay.
We're good.
Everything's fine.
Don't poop on me.
The little... the poops are like such a full shape.
Like a whole poop.
Like it couldn't be like a little pellet.
No.
It's like a whole poop.
I'm gonna try opening that door again.
Um...
Maybe it needs to get like right on top of it.
Ah!
No worries.
Did I open it?
I don't even know.
Oh my gosh.
Run!
Maybe using the d-pad would be better.
I don't know why I was...
Okay.
It did open?
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Run.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, throw!
No!
I opened it again.
Run!
Wait!
Oh!
I thought there was a guy down there.
We're fine.
Don't go through there.
Oh.
What?
Why did you stand back up?
Mr. Adventurer.
Press down and drop a b-bomb at your feet.
So funny thing, I'll show you.
Oh.
Maybe... Hold on.
I'll show you.
Pretty sure...
You can die to your own bombs.
Cause it's happened to me.
I haven't played so much of this.
I got to stage, like, three, I think.
So...
Oh!
Oh, how did I live?
How did I live?
I don't know.
Yes!
Wait, eleventh?
Okay, you can't crouch and move.
Okay.
There's lots of treasure in here, though.
Nice.
Oh.
Okay, nice, nice.
Wait.
How did I jump so high before?
Hey!
Throw!
Yeah!
Wait, I can't get through there, actually.
Now that I think about it.
Oh.
How do you get past here?
Huh?
Open the door for me, little worm!
Oh, there's more worms over here, too.
Wait!
Oh my gosh.
When you jump, you can't move.
Okay, move around.
I made it to the 52nd...
52nd?
54th?
Whatever one that was.
Good job, everybody.
Let's try going through that first door.
Actually, I know that leads to the second one.
I was really curious about the other one.
Which is...
How did I live?
Oh!
Mom and Mum!
Yippee!
Where was that door?
I think it's a pain in the butt that the enemies are randomized.
I stood up too soon.
No way!
Okay, okay, okay.
That's fine.
Okay, second zone.
Wait, those go down.
Oh, treasure, treasure.
Nice.
I don't want to be got by my own bomb though.
Okay, nice, nice.
Let's go up.
I have no idea where I'm going.
It's okay.
Only 600 seconds.
I know, right?
At least it's unlimited bombs.
Oh my god.
That was close.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, get out of here.
Get out of here.
Run.
Nice.
That was close.
Okay, this guy again.
Nice.
Where's the door?
Oh.
Oh, but there's a treasure down there.
Third zone.
If you run, jump and immediately jump again, you'll jump higher.
Oh my god.
Are you sure about that?
That was so close.
Oh my god.
You can't move when you jump.
So it's like...
You have to... Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Huh.
Whoa.
This dang fish.
Huh.
Okay.
Full commit every jump.
It feels like...
Let's try this way.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
This guy was targeting me.
It feels like...
Jump King in that regard.
You know what I mean?
Where it's like...
Jump King.
You have to...
Commit.
Commit to your...
To your jump.
Jump.
Oh my god.
Oh.
It's a good thing I didn't jump.
Jump.
Wait.
Six though?
What?
What just happened?
Wait.
How did I get here?
Oh my god.
What is that?
I got something.
Eight.
So...
Oh my god.
I knew there were warps in this game but I don't know where they are so I'm kind of just like...
Oh.
We'll find it.
Maybe the pitfall is a secret.
You think so?
Okay.
We can't go that way.
This pitfall right here?
I have room.
I have one life left.
I have one life left and I don't remember how I got to the sixth zone to get those shoes.
Should I risk it for the biscuit?
No.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Just throw the bomb.
There's no risk in throwing the bomb.
Only my sanity.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
I don't mean to scream.
This game is just a little stressful is all.
Hey.
Oh.
I ended up killing him.
Oh my god.
The momentum.
No.
Get me going.
Oh.
The mystery adventure.
The adventure starts.
Okay.
To give you guys any idea, I believe for Korone, it took her 11, almost 12 hours to beat.
And for Game Center, for Arino, it took him 8 hours, I think, to beat.
And he used a guy.
Which actually...
Which actually I have as well.
This is the same exact one that he used on the show.
And it shows you...
It shows you the different warps and things that you can do.
So if we get stuck, we're gonna use it.
Okay?
I'm not gonna use it.
So...
We're gonna use the guide.
If we get stuck.
Okay?
I'm ser...
I'm serious.
Nice subway map.
Oh my gosh.
That was so close.
I don't know what the hitbox is on this thing at all.
Wait.
So...
This one took me further.
Maybe I should do this one then.
11th zone.
It'll tell you in the level where the warp is.
I...
I'm not sure.
It was this one.
Wasn't it?
That we...
52nd!
Can't believe...
Streamer is a cheater.
Oh my god.
It's not cheating!
Why would they provide the map and the guide if they didn't want you to use it?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay.
This is where I learn how to jump at least.
Hold on.
Oh.
There's a bug!
Okay.
So far, so good.
What is that?
Oh.
I got a clock.
But also, I don't think calling me a cheater is very nice.
So please actually don't do that.
Because I think if I...
You could call me that if I use save states.
But I'm not.
So please don't.
Okay.
Umm...
Are there two of you now?
Why won't you shoot bombs when I tell you to?
Oh my gosh.
No!
Go away!
Okay.
Wow, I traveled.
No one means it maliciously.
They're just teasing.
Yeah, but I'm telling you I don't want the teasing today.
At least not that kind of teasing.
Because I don't think it's really fair to me.
Thank you!
You can say skill issue all you want.
I just think I take offense when it comes to cheating because I have too much pride.
Even if I have cheated in my life, I don't like to admit.
Or my afterlife even.
This one.
Okay.
She's a loser, but not a cheater.
Oh my gosh.
Go away bug!
Yes!
Aim!
Okay, nice.
Nice.
I did it!
Oh my god, please.
Thank you.
Is there... why does this look so suspicious?
Okay, maybe it's nothing.
I don't want to get caught by the bugs.
No!
Please!
Okay, okay.
Oh, okay.
It's just part of the set design.
Please!
Let's go.
Wait, do I have eight lives?
Mommy!
Wait, how do I kill the mommy?
Oh!
Three bombs.
Okay.
One.
Two.
Three.
Can I jump over this?
Oh!
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
I can jump...
Up?
Wait.
Oh my god!
No!
They're coming from behind!
Oh my god.
No, don't kill me.
Maybe I jump here?
Open.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
Fifty-seventh zone.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh, wow!
Oh my god!
What
is going on?
Okay, just go.
Yo!
Oh my god!
No, no, no, no, no!
Maybe he can... maybe... maybe...
Can I jump?
Okay.
Oh god, please get me out of here!
I don't wanna be in there!
Land is not so anymore!
I hate it!
Okay.
We can just stay up top for now.
Probably.
It's probably safe.
Okay.
He's gonna fall.
Idiot.
Oh my god, my eyes!
Two!
Oh!
Throw, throw, throw, throw, throw!
Okay.
Okay, we're gaming.
We're gaming.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh!
Nice!
We got both of them!
We're gaming!
Please get me out of this zone!
Please!
I thought that would work too.
Oh my god!
Don't take me back to zone... what is this?
57?
This zone sucks.
This zone sucks so much.
My eyes!
How am I supposed to play like this?
Thank god you have unlimited bombs.
But not unlimited time.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I had no idea.
Come on!
Die already!
Okay.
But not me.
I'm gonna wait for him to drop.
Yeah.
Okay.
Save.
That was close.
I always see something on like the right side of my screen.
It's just gonna fall right off.
No!
I don't think it's worth it, you guys.
I'm staying in this zone.
I don't think it's worth it.
I'd rather just reset.
Okay.
I just gotta be good.
I just gotta get good.
Speedrun.
Okay.
Just...
Run and jump man!
Oh my god.
I can't with these guys.
The slimes.
Oh.
Hooyah!
I'm just gonna die.
I don't wanna do this stage anymore.
We'll come back to it when we have to come back to the 57th stage.
No!
Please!
Rip the rave cave.
Why?
Okay.
The mystery begins.
Oh my god.
Why did I...
It's okay.
They said that if a...
They say that if a bird poops on you, it's good luck.
I think.
So don't worry about it.
Why is this guy coming up from behind me?
Don't worry about everybody.
Now, also here...
I was able to get to the sixth zone.
I can only see green now.
Me too, honestly.
What?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Let me try going to the left actually.
Can I make it through there?
Oh.
Never mind.
Wait.
Oh, treasure.
I don't know what the treasure is worth.
I don't know if you can only get things through picking them up, like the items that we found, or if you can get things in treasure as well.
I'm not sure.
The warp is all the way to the right.
Yeah, but I wanted to see if there was a second door as well on the left.
It was up here though, wasn't it?
Okay.
Okay, there it is.
But the treasure...
Oh well.
Alright, third zone.
I forgot about this area, to be honest.
I forgot about the fish.
Ah!
I sent a Streamlabs warning about the flashing lights.
But it got backed up.
Oh, thank you for try...
Oh, heads up.
They might have fixed on the switch.
But I remember one stage having horrible flashing lights.
I see your warning.
I'm heeding your warning.
There's like no warning for the fish though.
And it's kind of messing me up.
Oh!
I was so close too.
I'm so frustrated.
I was so close.
Okay.
That's it.
That's a cute passing that level.
We'll see if we...
There's a warp past it though, you know, so we don't have to do it again.
As a certified kusage enthusiast, I've been waiting for nearly 3 years for this.
Well, the time has come, unfortunately.
Sorry, there was an error.
Oh!
I killed him!
Yeah, take that.
Stupid.
The fish!
The fish...
There's no way to know where they come either!
Oh my god!
I
waited for a fish to come!
I waited!
Oh my god.
The fish also waited.
No, I'm not raging yet.
The fish comes every 225 frames.
So it just happens to be every time I jump, eh?
Boom boom.
Look at how happy our guy is.
Go on his little Atlantis adventure.
What could you think the treasure is?
Of Atlantis.
Or not the treasure.
The mystery?
Oh my god.
The mystery of Atlantis.
Also!
There was the one where we warp!
To the sixth stage.
What was it?
It was on the third stage.
What hole?
Oh!
Sorry, I was not looking.
You fell in the pit.
Yeah, but I don't remember which pit it was.
There were a lot of pits.
Not the arm variety.
Though I wish they were.
Wow, there's a party going on in there.
Da da da da da da da da da da da da da.
Da da da da da da da da da da da da.
You would think that throwing a second bomb would like keep them down, you know what I mean?
But it does not.
In fact, they are immune.
Oh my gosh.
The best thing about streaming this game is the genuine hot tips and wild lies of trolls and one guys are indistinguishable.
It's true!
Actually, this time we can get the treasure down here.
Let's get the treasure.
What could it be?
Because this game is just...
You could say, drop a bomb here and you'll get to level 55 and you could be right!
You could be absolutely correct!
And who am I to...
Oh, there's more.
Who am I to say that you're incorrect?
Oh, nice.
Wait, there's even more!
What is the point of going all the way down here?
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna run out of time though.
Maybe.
Wait, is it just infinite level?
Huh?
I'm gonna run out of time though.
Wait, just keep going, keep going.
Oh!
There's another door!
Ninth zone!
Okay.
And we got...
What is that?
Hold on...
I got a...
Something.
Eight!
Eighth zone!
Huh?
What?
Wait, I haven't been here though before, right?
Oh my god.
Thank goodness I threw that.
The momentum is definitely gonna bite me in the butt.
Dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun.
It's in the zone.
I don't know where I'm at.
Kwee!
There we go.
Nice.
Big jump.
It's making me wanna pass more of the regular doors and find the secret.
Oh!
Ah!
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna go from here.
Ah!
Dun-dun-dun-dun-dun-dun.
Kwee!
The overcorrection.
I know because like when you jump you instinctly wanna like...
You instinctly want to press on like, you know...
To move forward.
Cause you're just like, oh my gosh.
And then the momentum too.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Kwee!
I think it's very funny that the guide to this game basically encourages you to like...
The guide is just like, oh by the way, there are warps.
Like, you can just totally...
You can just totally skip a bunch of this game if you really want to.
Ah!
Hi,
man.
Hello.
If I were a hidden door...
I'd be right...
Right there.
Alright.
I'd be right here.
Dang.
I tried.
Oh my gosh, please.
There we go.
Where is the door here anyway?
We haven't seen it yet.
Jumping in this game is so...
I died to my OPA.
No, Biggie.
Oh, that was close.
That was a close one.
No, Biggie.
I'm getting the hang of the jumping though.
I think.
Oh my god.
That was close.
That was so close.
Oh my god.
That was close too.
Because I could have died to my own bomb again.
Oh
my gosh.
We made it.
Okay.
This is gonna be like...
Do I even have time to make it through this?
Okay, hold on.
Oh gosh.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I think if I just drop...
Oh, I ran out of time.
Yo.
Okay.
Speedrun.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
I think I pixel perfect that.
Wait.
Okay.
Yo, I'm gaming?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought like...
Oh my god.
I was like, what killed me on the wall?
Okay.
Nice.
No, no, not nice.
Okay.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Where's the door?
Did someone sign the door to darkness?
No, not treasure.
Where's the door?
Where's...
Tenth zone.
Let's go.
Oh, no.
No, wait.
No, no, no, no.
I know this zone.
I think Arino spent like three hours on this zone.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Star.
This game is making me stressed.
I'm not even playing it.
I want the star though.
I don't think I can get it.
We'll come back for you.
It's a nice...
sunny day.
Can you jump on the clouds?
No, I don't think so.
I don't know.
I didn't try.
Back to zone one, everybody.
Oh, good troller.
Are you good?
I should have jumped.
I think jumping on the clouds would be too kind.
The game would be like...
I did it again.
I saw the one guy and I just ignored the other guy.
First in many months.
Ghosty.
Thank you.
Need an item for cloud walking.
Okay.
I should just jump over these guys.
Now which way do I want to go?
Why do you have so much poop?
What are these birds eating?
They have so much poop.
You're humming along to the beat.
This is the best.
Which way do we go, guys?
They eat too much fat.
They're eating my dead body once I'm dead.
My corpse.
That's why they're so...
That's why they're able to eat...
or poop so much.
Because they're just constantly feeding.
I'm gonna game over in the first sound.
Okay.
Which way do we go, though?
It was stage 3.
That got us to stage 6.
So let's try and get to stage 3 and figure out how to get to stage 6.
We'll drop down.
Click.
This way.
Good plan.
Okay.
Still no go that way.
Treasure.
Please.
Wait.
Yeah, we're going to the second one.
We're going to the first door, I mean.
Because that got us to stage 3.
This one right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
First, can I help it?
They're just really nervous around you.
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
So I got past a little bit, I think.
Before I fell.
Should I try this one?
Should I try this one, you think?
These fish, I know.
Okay.
No!
I can't remember where I...
Maybe it was a tiny one like this.
Okay, I'm just going to try this one.
Nope.
Happy one month.
Thank you guys so much!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I'm playing this.
I have one month.
One month of membership.
Thank you everybody.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
This is the one I just tried.
It was one of these, wasn't it?
Oh, fish going!
I don't know which one it was!
Yeah, thanks for 200k.
Okay.
I swear, I think they wait for you to jump.
I don't think it's every 7 seconds.
I think they wait for you to jump and then just intercept you.
It's so rude!
I think they wait for you to like do an action.
Oh!
It's not that one.
Ugh!
Hey!
Oh!
I don't know which one.
I don't know!
This game is 100% designed to be rude.
I agree.
Ah!
I don't think I got... I don't think I got...
I don't think I got it.
I don't think it was this far that I made it.
Oh my gosh!
Fish, fish, fish, fish.
Six, seven!
You know what, let's just keep going then.
One, two, three, four, five...
Oh, oh yeah!
Sorry, I pressed the wrong button.
Was it worth it?
Okay, we're gonna find it now.
It wasn't this one.
It was... not that one.
This one!
No.
Maybe it was...
Maybe it was the one after that.
Maybe this one.
Wait.
This one?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
Six zone!
Oh my god.
I got an item!
I got shoes!
Oh no, wait.
This one was really hard.
No.
You know what, it's fine because we wasted some lives on level three, so it's whatever.
Don't worry about it.
We wasted some lives on level three, so...
Okay, we gotta get to level three without dying.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Oh.
Thanks, VeraLint.
Is this Takeshi's challenge?
I think it's on par.
Ta-da.
Oh, ba-da-da-ba.
Second zone!
This jeopardizes your goal.
It's okay.
This one's easy.
There's no pitfalls.
Just gotta avoid these guys.
Why am I so weak?
I can't even handle a hermit crab.
Oh my god.
How did I live that?
What is this?
Atlantis is so mysterious.
Truly.
The most mysterious place.
Okay.
Third zone.
Have you seen the size of those hermit crabs?
Still.
They're really cool, too.
Like, they're wearing their sunglasses and...
Okay.
Now I have to find this one.
I like this.
I personally like the mint center CX arrow we've got.
I don't mind.
Like, I think...
Some people are just like I hate playing rage games.
Because, you know, they're designed to make you rage.
But I personally am like a fan of...
Being like...
Of...
Hopefully beating them.
Oh my god!
No!
Okay.
We have three lives.
Like, I think it's like the best feeling in the world to clear something that is meant to be so frustrating.
Okay, it was one...
I see the fish!
I see the fish and my finger still says, A!
You know what?
I think I'm just gonna die.
Actually, no.
I'm not.
I will continue on.
I will continue onward.
When the going gets tough, you'll pull through like you always do.
Thank you!
Okay.
It was...
This one!
Yes!
Oh my god, please, please!
Nice!
Okay, eighth zone!
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright.
I wonder what the... the boosts don't make me faster or anything.
I don't...
think.
I hope not.
Please, god, don't give me more speed in this game.
I will continue.
I will cry.
I will...
If I have to go any further or faster than I have...
Please, actually, just give me...
Like...
Just stop the momentum.
That would be the better gift.
Truly.
When they like start coming back to life, these little hermit crabs, it's like two seconds that they give you a warning.
It's crazy.
Okay.
Momentum.
I felt so close.
Okay.
That was so close!
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I can just drop there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Sorry.
Oh my god, I'm so stressed.
Okay, treasure chest.
Okay.
Nice.
The time limit!
It's so brutal!
You would think that 900 seconds is a lot.
Even Mario gives you like a thousand, doesn't...
Don't they?
Sometimes I gotta take my time.
Not in...
No, there's no time in Atlantis.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
Let's wait for this guy to go down.
Yep.
There we go.
Okay, here.
Okay.
Oh!
Pain!
You know what?
Let's say 1%.
We're at...
We're at 1%.
Oh, wow.
What's this level?
It's funny because I can't...
I can like kind of control this guy.
Like, I can jump, but I...
I can't throw anything.
And also, I didn't make that jump either.
I don't...
I don't understand.
Wait!
Oh, I ended up dying.
Okay, let's go.
There's no better way than I'd want to spend my Saturday.
No better way than I'd want to spend my Saturday, traveling...
Okay, I said 900 seconds.
These are way faster than seconds.
Oh!
No better way than spend my Saturday, just put 2% now.
I'm dying on purpose, by the way, so that we can just...
I wonder if there's a way for me to just read this.
Reset.
I don't think so.
Just let me...
Just let me die already.
No better way than to spend my Saturday.
When I'm trying to die, the deaths feel so...
Oh wait.
I instinctively just jumped over.
You could be watching an idol live and here you are.
Where are you going?
Where would I be watching an IdleLive?
I'm not in Japan.
Hello.
Stage 2.
You could be watching IdleLive a lot on YouTube.
So true.
Actually, it's like so frustrating sometimes being for an Idle fan because like they film shows.
I know they do.
I see the cameras in the back, but they don't post them like 99% of the time.
They never post the show itself.
So if I miss a show, like that's kind of it.
And sometimes they'll perform like a special set list.
It's mostly frustrating for birthdays because they'll perform like a special set list.
And I'm like, no, please.
Please, I just want to see you perform this song.
I think it is for them to like watch back and practice and like, you know...
See like where maybe they made mistakes or certain parts.
But like it's still so... it's just so sad.
Okay, I'm waiting for fish.
Okay, it was the third one.
Here.
Fish.
Okay.
This one.
Six zone!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
It came out of nowhere.
Okay.
Gotta go fast.
Okay, this is not very fast.
Phew.
Yeah.
Faster!
Nasal man!
Please!
Faster!
Just... ride like you're... you little legs.
It was a ride, just ride!
Oh my god!
Nice.
Okay.
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
This part is tricky, but we got this.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, I don't have this.
Okay.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Please.
You know what?
Screw it.
I don't have-
We're fine.
Oh my god.
Where did you come from?!
I even threw the bomb and it didn't even affect him!
Just run.
Run and jump.
Oh my god.
Okay.
No!
Oh my god.
Oh!
I think actually that did stop him.
I don't know why this stage gives me so much trouble.
It's so much hopping.
Oh no, and he's right there.
Okay.
Momentum.
Don't forget the basics of CQC boss or something.
Yeah, thanks.
Oh, the momentum.
That wasn't even me over-correcting at that time.
Okay, just in case.
Sometimes I die.
Sometimes I don't.
The game's...
The game doesn't even know...
I don't know what my own hitbox is.
I have no idea.
You guys, I don't think we're making it to level 9, so...
You aren't playing through OBS, are you?
No, I'm actually not!
I'm actually not playing through OBS.
It's only been an hour!
Maybe try with OBS.
Maybe I'm too used to OBS now.
Where did the other door in here take me?
I can't remember.
Just run!
Just run and jump!
There we go.
Oh gosh, there's so many tiny little holes!
Oh, I thought I was gonna die there!
I thought for sure I would die there!
Okay, third zone.
No fish!
Sorry, I'm allergic...
...to fish.
Okay.
Fish.
Fish!
Here.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot.
Why is everything pooping on me?
Okay.
Ah, please!
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's go!
I thought I was gonna land on top of that other one, so...
Okay.
The music in this, I think, stresses me out.
It's so fast-paced, you know?
Oh my god, I thought I was gonna die!
Oh, I thought I was gonna die!
Big leaps.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Very good.
Okay, nothing here.
Nothing here.
Okay.
Shoo!
Gah!
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I have to wait...
I jumped, but I... didn't.
Maybe do it soon enough.
Oh...
Come on, come on, come on!
There's no time to lose!
Oh my god.
Why wasn't he affected by the bomb?
Sometimes it really doesn't read my inputs, but that's okay.
Like there, I tried jumping just then.
Might be my controller.
No, no.
It's just a skill issue.
Real gamers don't blame the controller.
I'm a gamer.
Yeah, we do.
Actually, maybe that's the most gamer thing to do.
Is to blame the controller.
Why?
There we go.
Please.
Thank you.
Okay.
We made it to the treasure chest.
Okay, just don't even try.
Just go.
Please.
Please just make it to the door.
Oh my god.
Tenth zone.
Oh, tenth zone.
Okay.
Clouds.
Oh my gosh.
No, I missed the star.
Uh oh.
It's Jover.
It's Jover, you guys.
I missed the...
I missed it.
Maybe there will be another one.
That was bad.
Oh wait, we got another chance.
We got another chance.
Hi...
Hi.
I was too...
I got it!
I got...
Oh my god.
Phew...
That was from here, right?
Yes.
No, no, no, no, no!
Okay, okay.
This is the most stressful level.
Oh my god, this is the most stressful level I've ever played in my entire afterlife.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you guys.
I can barely breathe.
Oh my gosh, I can barely breathe.
You're struggling.
You're stressing me out.
What am I doing?
It's the game!
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
I think this level wouldn't be as bad if I didn't have to go through level 8 before.
Oh no!
If I didn't have to go through level 8 before...
I would have...
Called it, man.
Hey.
You guys...
That's why I don't have a death counter.
Because...
No way.
It's...
When...
When someone way better at games than me...
Takes three hours on one stage, I think...
I think we, uh...
Uh, you know what?
I'm gonna go up.
I think we can...
Recognize the trouble we are in.
And I have to get it eventually.
I have to get it eventually.
It has to come eventually.
Death count, yes.
Pretty much.
Okay, fish.
Fish.
Oh, that was close.
Okay.
Here.
Six zone.
Okay.
Nice!
Level 8.
My...
The pain of my existence level 8.
Because it's so long!
It's also like so...
Oh my god.
It's also so long.
It takes so long to get through it.
Maybe it's just me.
Maybe, you know what?
Looking at it, it's actually not that long.
I think it's just me.
Okay.
I ran and jumped!
I ran and I jumped!
And I still only did a tiny jump.
But...
Oh...
That could have been close.
But...
Come on!
Be careful!
I didn't do anything there!
Come on!
I didn't even do anything there!
I just...
I just jumped...
And the guy ran and decided to run on its own!
I threw my bomb too late.
Look on the bright side.
You could be playing a harder NES game.
This game is easy!
Look on the bright side.
This game... a baby could do it.
Thank you.
You know what...
Always look on the bright side.
I don't know why sometimes I die...
to the bombs and sometimes I don't.
I think if I jump, I don't die to the bomb.
Maybe.
Thanks for the super chat!
I'll read it.
Is there a reason for... oh wait.
Insane timer?
I have no idea.
Because this game, I think, was designed to...
literally hate you.
It's designed to make you...
so sad.
It's designed to make you really, really sad.
Please.
Okay.
There we go.
It's designed to make you cry.
We're so close.
Gaming.
Okay.
We have only three lives left.
Thank you Kyoki!
I feel like I'm at least getting better at the previous level though, so...
Okay.
Got the star.
Oh my god!
No!
Jump is so tricky!
One life left, everybody.
What if I go backwards?
What if I go this way?
Nevermind!
No!
Jump...
And jump!
Poop.
Door.
You earned that game over.
Yeah, I did.
What was she cooking?
Look, I have one life left.
What am I gonna do?
Experiment when I have...
When I have 50 lives?
This game needs to give you 50 lives, speaking of.
The life...
They need to give you more lives in this game.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I didn't think I would make that.
I didn't think I would make that at all.
Okay.
There are cheats that let you add lives?
No way!
Really?
This one I can take a little bit slower because...
Oh my gosh.
Because it's right like here that way.
Fish.
It's right here.
You're just holding back on how good you are to make us feel better?
I... I...
I encourage you.
Play this game.
Play it.
I encourage you.
I'm not looking to beat any records.
Oh my god.
No!
That was so dirty.
Oh my gosh.
But no.
Actually play it.
Try it.
I'm not trying to beat any records here.
But just to give you an idea.
Korone-san...
Took...
About 12 hours.
And...
And Game Center CX...
Between two people...
Arino took about...
Eight and a half...
Eight hours?
Eight and a half hours?
So...
What is the speedrun on this game?
What?
What is the...
What is the speedrun on this game?
I don't even want to know actually.
I think I'll throw up.
Wait.
Uh oh.
I'm losing a lot of time.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
I have to be quicker with these.
No.
Oh gosh.
I gotta be fast.
No!
Three minutes?
Oh.
For task run though?
Come on.
That doesn't count.
Task run doesn't count.
I mean for real people.
I'll look in a second.
I'm concentrating.
Holy cow.
How did I make that?
I think it's just mint.
Just mint gaming.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
I need to make this...
Why?
Please sir.
There we go.
Okay.
Here is the tough one.
I think...
I don't think 225 is task?
Really?
No way.
I need this guy to run.
I had to stop falling from the ceiling.
He's scaring me.
He's stressing me out a little bit.
Nooo... Why you gotta be down there?
Wait...
Okay...
Okay, here...
Here's where I really mess up, so...
Okay, there we go.
Nice, nice, nice hoop!
I think I have time!
But I'm not gonna risk it!
Just go!
Don't risk it for the biscuit!
It's not worth it!
It's not even delicious!
It's dry!
Don't risk it for the biscuit!
Okay...
Oh, hold on...
Hold on...
Goodbye...
Where are the mods?
Okay...
Hey...
They're probably... They're probably just like, We can't watch this anymore.
This is...
This is too stressful.
This is too stressful on my little heart!
How did I make that?
Oh my gosh, please, please, please...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no...
Oh, the timer is just going!
It's just going!
Oh, that was a pretty good run, though.
That was a pretty good run.
All things...
All things considered...
You...
Oh, well, I didn't make it anyway.
Oh, gosh...
You're getting better.
I don't think...
I don't think there's a way to get better at this game.
I'll be honest.
I think this game is just so...
So evil.
This game is not meant to...
You're not supposed to get better at this game.
I don't think...
I think...
I don't know how much skill comes into this.
That's what I'm saying!
I have to like...
At least with this one, I feel like I have to memorize...
Why?
I have to memorize how...
Where I stand...
The standing placement and...
How much I press down on the button...
And everything!
I have to memorize so much!
Sorry, I totally...
Game was made by a sadist.
I'm gonna start up my...
I'm gonna...
I got a coffee.
It might not actually be good for me to have this...
Because it'll make my hands shaky, but...
I'm okay.
Yummy!
Rage back down to zero!
Yummy, yummy!
You're lucky stars.
This isn't super pitfall.
You'd be mentally barfing.
You wanna take that back?
Actually...
Hold on.
I'm gonna die.
Because I do wanna see how far I can...
Um...
Okay, hold on.
Let's get to the level 54 again.
I wanna go that route.
Because I'm pretty sure that there's another warp there.
Because...
From what I remember, there's a way to get all the way to level 99.
But...
So...
Sorry.
Maybe I should have done this before I...
No, no.
We're not gonna go through the rave room.
I think you can skip it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna check the guide real quick once we're done.
Yeah, there's a hidden door.
Okay, okay.
I thought so.
So we're gonna...
We're gonna die.
And we're gonna...
Because I do wanna see...
I mean, if I can just beat the game by getting to level 99...
Okay.
Was that my last one?
Yeah.
Okay.
Strategy guide.
Let me see now.
Okay.
Here.
So...
11.
This is...
Wait, is that where we...
No.
11...
52.
Yes, yes, yes.
91?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
So 1 to 11.
Okay.
It doesn't say how I get to level 91.
Hmm.
What the hell is this map?
This is the levels for this game!
So you can go 1, 2, 3, 4...
Wait, you can't even go from 4 to 5?
What is it?
Wait...
Where is level 5?
There... there is... huh?
Oh, it's... Oh, I see it!
It's below 2.
Okay.
5...
Can also get you to 24...
But how do you get 4 to 5?
What the heck is happening?
5 to 6?
6...
And then 6 to 7...
No, 6 can go to 8 and 9... Oh, you can go...
Wait, huh?
But we're gonna go to 11...
And then we're gonna go to 52...
I can't read that...
Jimetsuwapu...
And then you can go to zone 91...
But what's the warp?
The 91 to 95...
To 93?
96?
Yeah, we can... we can get the final... Oh...
Oops...
We can get there, maybe...
11 is the highway...
I see... I get it...
What about 20 to 100?
Yeah, how do we... Okay, 9, 8, 20...
Right?
Wait, okay, hold on...
Oh...
So 9 to 8 to 20... Wait, 9 to 8...
To 20 to 100...
That's a plausible... possible path...
Yeah, let's try it out...
Sorry, I keep clicking on the wrong thing...
Okay...
There we go... Okay...
It was from 2, right?
2, 9, 8, 20...
Oh,
2, 2, 2...
Wait, okay, 2 to a...
That's probably the one where we run...
Past this door here...
So let's just stay down...
Stay down...
We'll stay down...
Oh my god... Oh, that was close...
Phew...
That was so close...
Run past you...
Da da da...
Okay, run past you...
I don't remember where the door is...
Oh, that's so unfair...
They're on top of the treasure box...
I don't have much time though...
So I gotta zip...
I gotta zippity...
Okay, never mind...
Door...
Did someone say...
The door...
To darkness?
Okay, 9th zone...
Wait, was this right?
Was this correct?
I think this gives me an extra life...
From 9 to 8...
Oh, that's right, yes...
And then we went back to 8...
Yes, yes, yes...
And then 8 to 20...
Wait...
Oh, no...
There's a...
Oh...
Oh, god...
Okay...
Oh...
For some reason, my brain did not comprehend that...
Okay...
Let's look for any places like...
That a door...
Like, I feel like in here...
You know, like...
In a little dip at the bottom...
Like a...
A door...
Oh, wait...
Unless I run past...
Oh, shoot...
Wait, I already messed up then at that point...
I've already messed up...
But that's okay...
Because I've wasted a lot of time...
I don't know if it's a hidden door...
Or if it's a...
Door past the initial door...
But that's okay...
This song in particular will haunt me...
You wouldn't think a ghost could get haunted...
But...
Okay, nice...
I touched him...
What if I'm like really deathly allergic to shellfish or something...
And so that's why...
It's like really dangerous for me...
To touch these guys, you know...
I'm just so deathly allergic to shellfish...
Oh my gosh...
I almost overcorrected that...
That would have been bad...
Nice...
Alright, that was...
Alright, now we...
Okay, okay!
Geez, you can hit yourself...
Yeah, you can...
But only...
I think it's only if you hit yourself in the face...
Thank you for the pink!
Thank you!
I mean, you could blame me for like throwing it preemptively...
But also can you blame me for throwing it preemptively...
Because like...
Sometimes I'm like, am I gonna make this?
Like, see?
Like that!
Okay, nice.
We wait for him to drop down, then we jump across.
Like so.
Okay.
Now we're running past this door.
Hopefully, it's shortly past.
Got something.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Please, please!
20th zone!
Keyword!
Nagoya!
What just happened?
Why am I back here?
Why am I... Why am I... Why am I back... Why am I... Why am I back here?
Was I not supposed... Was I supposed to ignore that door?
Keyword!
And the moi!
I didn't know this was a Metal Gear game!
I threw my bomb too late.
Wait!
I think you have to go backwards on 20th?
If we make it... If we make it there again, we'll try!
If we make it there again, we'll try!
Though!
I'll be honest.
Even if I get to level 100...
Though!
I'll be honest.
Even if I get to level 100...
Um, through this method...
I think I'll keep... I don't know.
It feels too easy, right?
Like...
I've only been playing for 2 hours.
Less than 2 hours, so...
I do want to try maybe the other method.
The 11 to 50 to... Oops, I forgot where I was at.
To... To... I don't know.
Is there anyone who has played this game?
Levels... Levels 1?
Oh my gosh.
Ugh!
Okay, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Levels... Like, in complete order, I wonder.
Okay, nice.
Oh,
wait!
Can I go back?
Can I like... No.
Oh my god!
No way!
No!
And it reset the counter!
Yo!
Oh my god!
Are you kidding me right now?
That's... incredible.
Best game ever!
Do I bomb them?
Keyword, Nagoya.
Okay...
Oh!
Wait, I can jump on these guys.
No, no, no, no!
Oh!
Nagoya.
Keyword, Nagoya.
I'm afraid to jump.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Na na na na na Na na na na na No.
I don't know yet.
Ah!
temperature.
Oh!
It sounds like a classical song.
Now, like...
Someone made when they were...
When they had scarlet fever or something like...
I am the Black Plague!
My mind is going...
Why didn't it stop him?
The bomb!
Maybe you have to jump on their heads in a certain order.
I have no idea.
It might be time to give up on this route.
If there was like no way... How do you do it though?
Do I have to blow them up maybe?
Like in a special way?
I'm just not sure.
So this must be endless A everyone is talking about.
Let's see.
Oh, please.
Uh oh, we've wasted a lot of time.
A lot of time.
I don't even know if I'll make it to the...
To level 10.
How do I do that?
I don't even know if I'll make it to level 10.
Shoot.
But if I do, I can just go back.
If you're still at this in 6 hours, we'll tell you how the Naglia room works.
You're too kind.
Kacho Arino also has mint clothes.
Oh, look at that.
It's closed now.
Isn't that kind of funny?
But also, you're right.
Arino does have...
Does have mint clothes.
The Naglia room is actually unsolvable?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by that?
And also, like, if I practice here...
Yeah, see, like...
But it's in the guide that you can go from 20 to...
It's solvable?
Do I have to, like, get it in their mouths?
It's a secret code.
Na...
Go...
Yeah.
Something to do with the plants.
I think this is my last life anyway, so it's probably fine to...
If you were in Naglia...
No.
Umm...
That wasn't my last one.
Wait!
Na...
Seven.
So, seven there.
Go!
One, two, three, four, five...
Yeah!
Eight?
I don't know.
Actually...
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Do I have to, like, get it on top of their heads?
Like, if I...
Do I have to, like, blow up...
Like, seven on top of their heads?
Nagoya...
See, see, see, see?
Oh my god, that's, like, so hard.
That's actually...
So...
So tricky!
Oh, so close!
Ah...
I think I...
Oh, dang.
Oh...
Ah!
Ah...
It's, like, pixel perfect.
Drop it by crouching?
What if I...
Oh...
No...
It doesn't need...
One, two...
How do I even know if it's working?
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Nine...
10...
11...
12...
13...
17...
18...
19...
21...
23...
25...
26...
27...
28...
29...
30...
31...
32...
33...
34...
35...
36...
37...
5...
Island...
No...
15...
32...
The... oh my god... truly a mysterious place.
That was so close.
Very naso indeed.
Oh, I'm just gonna jump over you guys.
Yeah, I'm still not raging.
I think I'm still okay.
Nice.
Has it honestly been a month already?
That's crazy.
Here I am.
Not raging.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Okay,
eleventh zone!
I don't remember what this zone was like.
Oh yes, I do remember!
I have to blow myself up here.
Let's get some treasure though.
Very nice.
I have to blow myself up here.
Okay, then we go to the 52nd zone.
52nd!
Oh, I do remember this zone!
Locusts.
Please.
Please!
Leave me alone!
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Oh no no no no no no no!
Please!
Okay, just keep going.
Please throw a bomb!
Okay.
Nice.
Wait!
Wait wait wait!
This is where the...
This is where we're supposed to find the other door!
The other door to darkness!
Oh gosh.
Um...
Oh...
Is it on one of these platforms?
Oh shoot.
Um...
Because if we go down here...
Oh shoot.
Yes!
Okay, good.
Maybe like...
Uh...
Shoot.
Shoot!
No no no, I can't go through that one!
Oh my god, please.
Uh...
Is it past the other door?
I don't think so...
I don't think I can...
I don't think I can jump over that.
Unless...
Yeah.
Ugh!
Uh oh.
I can't go back.
I'm stuck here.
I can't go back!
Uh...
Shoot...
Oh!
Okay...
And we're stuck here too.
Now we're stuck here.
Ugh.
Okay.
That's fine.
It doesn't take much to get to the next level, so...
So...
To get to... from 11 to 50... whatever... 54.
So I think we'll be okay.
How does Mint know all of that?
All of what?
What do I know?
I don't know anything.
I don't know anything!
52.
Oh.
Thank you!
Two!
Nine!
Thank you!
I always love retro gameplay.
Yeah, I do too.
Until it's like this, you know?
Orly, that should've been mine.
That...
should've... oh wait.
I think I messed up, you guys.
Uh oh.
Go!
Okay, game over.
If I were a hidden door...
Where would I be?
Where?
Oh.
That was so close.
Gosha!
Thank you so much for the 50 gift!
Thank you!
Also, wait.
I'm so sorry.
Someone also superchatted the pink earlier.
I had a nap while listening to your screams and I woke up to a bee in my hair!
I like bees, but that freaked me out.
How's this...
How's this going?
Are you winning?
Shwanky!
I'm so sorry you had a bee in your hair.
What?
That sounds a little frightening.
She's winning.
Maybe like right here.
Not there.
Maybe where this treasure box is.
Shoot.
Never mind.
Do you think I...
Ugh.
Yeah.
Okay.
Not where the treasure box is.
Oh my god.
There we go.
What the...
I... I got that!
Excuse me!
I got that!
I got that so...
No.
This game cheated me.
Here?
I think I tried here before.
Also, if you're trying to say what it is in the chat, please don't because I am not asking for answers right now.
You know what?
Let's just try anywhere.
I didn't walk enough.
We lost the 50-50.
What's the... What were you betting on?
What are you betting on, huh?
It wasn't here.
Oh my goodness.
Shoot.
Oh my god!
I jumped too much now.
Maybe next to the treasure chest.
You're doing amazing.
Thank you.
Please.
Why does it...
Why can't it be consistent with the enemies?
You know?
All I'm asking for is...
Oh my god.
All I'm asking for is a little consistency here.
Just think about Nagoya.
Nagoya is the key word to beating this game.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I took out two bugs with one bomb!
You know what they say.
Two bugs with one bomb.
Wait.
I lost the timer again.
Yeah.
Take my wrath.
Take my...
fury!
I got bugged.
No, please stop coming for me.
I can't.
Is that a game over?
Yup.
Now I won't feel so bad.
Oh.
I dropped a bomb instead of jumping.
My bad.
Now I won't feel so bad if we get all the way to to the final levels because it's already been a challenge enough getting there.
...
and we gonna...
gosh ... You're totally bugged.
No, this game is genuinely a about the journey.
It's about something.
We are just a little guy trying to find Atlantis.
Okay.
Actually.
Are we in Atlantis?
Are we going to Atlantis or are we going to Atlantis?
I'm kind of confused about that part.
Because if we found Atlantis and we're here...
in Atlantis...
What's the mystery?
Why it's built like this?
No wonder everybody died in Atlantis.
Look how your society is built.
Here we go.
We're back.
Baby bug.
He just so, so slowly...
grazes my head.
It's so funny.
It's not funny at all.
It's so frustrating.
Okay, there we go.
And then if I hadn't made that jump...
that would have been so sad.
I can't throw another bomb...
until the one explodes.
Which also just really messes me up.
It really grinds my gears.
Yes.
Okay.
No, no, no, no.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay, here, here maybe.
Blow!
Yes!
That was what I was hoping for.
Throw!
Is it next to the other door?
They wouldn't do that, would they?
Uh oh.
There we go.
It's not next to the other door, is it?
I have to like throw it so...
Oh!
Okay, it's not.
Maybe if I throw it from here.
Maybe that's the key.
No?
Okay.
They're not trying to give me hints at all.
Bug!
But sometimes it's also pretty specific.
Where did I throw it from?
Oh, there, there, there.
Oh, no.
Time out!
It's okay.
We're gonna have to do a lot of trial and error for this.
So, honestly, it's best that we time out than getting bugged.
At least I...
Look at him.
What an idiot.
Now he's gonna drown!
Oh.
You don't drown, but I can.
Okay.
This is fine.
Where else could it be?
Oh, wait.
Oh my god!
Maybe, like, I stand here and throw it.
You know?
Maybe the opening is like a little...
Oh, shoot.
Blah!
He's built it for 50 seconds.
Okay.
It's not there.
It's there.
No.
Is it...
Did I try next to the treasure box?
I don't think I...
There we go.
Nice.
I don't think I...
Maybe if I aim from here.
Aim.
Okay.
I give up.
I don't know!
Can you get exploded by your own bombs?
You can.
You actually can.
Okay.
Actually, what if I do this instead?
Nope.
Why do you throw it so much, you dummy?
I'm gonna run out of time again.
Okay.
I want a hint.
Do you want a hint?
Yeah.
Just a hint.
Don't tell me where.
But just a hint.
Like, check...
Check...
Where the pillar meets three.
One moment!
Thank you!
Hint of the last platform.
Like...
Like right before the door?
Or where the door is?
Last platform.
So this platform?
Phew.
It's under there.
Under where?
Only one hint.
Last platform.
Okay.
So, wait.
If I...
I wanted to jump and then throw it back onto the other platform.
Oh, man.
No!
Mummy?
Sorry.
Oh.
Awww!
While we run out of lives, I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
I'm gonna go to the little ghosty's room.
I hope you do not mind.
I will be right back.
Let me make...
Okay.
I'll be right back while I go to the ghosty's room.
You guys get some water as well.
I'm back.
I'm still alive?
How am I still alive?
Game over!
Perfect timing, right?
Okay, I'm gonna look back at the guide one more time.
Is there something we missed about what it says for the route?
Can I zoom in a little bit more?
What kind of masochist do you have to be to go for a high score in this game?
No, thank you.
There's scoreboards!
If I'm not top 50, why even play?
I'm afraid of anyone that is... that holds a record in this game.
I'm terrified of anybody that holds a record in this game.
Hold on, I'm... I'm... bank yo... bank yo time.
Uh...
Okay, Sight Down is just the shortest.
Okay, that's what I figured, but...
Hmm...
But then...
What's the red route?
Oh, oh, oh, oh...
One, two, three, eight, ten...
Four...
Have we done four before?
What is this?
The star!
Okay, you get a bunch of items.
Oh, oh no!
What page were we on?
Uh...
Uh-oh, I lost my page.
Oh, there we go.
Twenty-five...
So it's the shortest, but it says it's an invincible route.
But ten!
We have to go through ten!
Okay, it says from ninety-seven to a hundred.
The shoes are...
You have to have the shoes.
Okay...
Interesting.
So from ninety-seven to a hundred, you have to have the shoes for this route.
But this one bypasses the one that we're doing.
The...
This one bypasses...
Actually, how many...
How many stages are in this red route versus the orange route?
Uh...
Let's see.
Can we get a coffee meter?
I only have one can.
So...
The shoes, you say.
The shoes here.
You get six.
So this is one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve.
Okay.
One, two...
Three...
Four...
Five...
Six...
Seven...
Eight...
Nine...
Ten.
Did I count a hundred on the first one?
I don't remember.
Twelve in the red route.
So it's not even that big of a difference.
Okay.
So we have our two routes.
I think we should...
We would have to go, right?
But I'm...
This one is called the invincibility route.
So what does that even mean?
I have to beat level ten though.
Oh, God.
And then this thing that I need the shoes worries me.
What's going on in 97 that I need the shoes, huh?
Try Nagoya route again.
What is it?
What does it say for that one?
Oh.
Ah, sorry.
I keep...
What is...
It's the blue route.
That's the high score route.
How does that even make any sense?
If you go from eight to twenty.
I guess you get the 400 points.
Oh no.
400...
Oh my God.
400 points.
You get a lot of points actually.
You get a ton of bajillion points.
Real question is how long is the longest route you can take?
I guess in regular order, right?
Okay.
I think... okay.
I'll try and get the uh... the...
We'll try for 52 again.
I wonder what this little thing is.
We'll try for 52 again and then...
I'll try and find it.
Okay.
Alright.
Ikimashou.
Where's my...
Okay.
Dark blue line looks really long.
Let's go try and find us a hidden passage.
You guys said the pit was the last platform.
We can give another hint when you're ready.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
Explosion!
Do you eventually loop around to loving this song?
Love is a strong word, I think.
Just as hate.
Hate and love are two sides of the same coin.
Right?
Right.
Woo!
Oh no!
I know I get pretty close to them but it's the only way I can ensure true and total death.
True and total death!
Okay.
If I just drop here.
Alright.
No...
Oh no no no no no!
It's okay.
We still have seven lives left.
Are you winning, Minto?
We're making progress.
Somehow.
We are making progress.
There's some progress being made.
We're level 54, you guys.
We're in the 50s.
Oh my gosh.
That was so close.
Ha!
That's what you get for getting too close to me.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
50 seconds!
How did you find out about this game originally?
I originally watched the Game Center CX.
But also I watched Korone play it.
And so...
I was...
Oh!
Wrong button.
Oh my gosh.
So dangerous here.
So that's what got me interested in playing it.
Oh!
What is Game Center CX?
Oh my gosh!
It's so awesome!
Game Center CX is like a show where this guy just tries a bunch of games.
And like...
He has like...
Some rage challenges.
Like he played Takeshi's Castle and everything.
And...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die!
The bug!
Japanese Ojisan Gamer Show.
It's really funny!
We love Arino Kacho.
It's really funny and...
Oh!
I flew!
I went flying!
Okay.
I like when there's only one bug there.
Makes things a little bit...
Easier.
I'm afraid of the other route just because of...
Oh my gosh.
I thought I was gonna die there.
Because I'd have to go through level 8 and 10.
But...
If that's what we gotta do...
A baby's gotta do what a baby's...
Gotta do.
I can't even get to the end of the platform anymore.
Man.
That was so close.
Oh.
Okay.
Never mind.
No!
Okay.
Last platform.
I'm just gonna blow up everywhere that I can.
The way I'm gonna blow up.
Okay.
Uh oh.
Oh I got one guy at least.
Please.
There we go.
Last platform.
Does this...
Maybe the hole in the fence is a hint?
I tried it though!
I tried it.
I'm gonna run out of time with this rave.
Like I thought maybe...
Shooting in there.
Oh nice.
Oh.
But it doesn't... doesn't do anything.
Nooo.
Maybe if I shoot from here...
No.
Jump and shoot.
Go away bug.
You're bugging me.
It's okay.
I was out of time anyway.
I don't...
I don't know.
Yeah.
I've blown up every spot of this place.
I don't even know that part.
Oh my gosh.
Go away.
Let's see.
Hmm.
Oh my god.
I overjumped.
I really wanna find that spot though.
Is this another drop down entrance?
I don't think so.
Oh my god.
I'm so sorry.
Whoop!
Poop!
Wow!
Why are you higher than the last guy?
Poop!
Ba-na-na-na-na!
Blow!
Okay, we're back, baby!
Why did I...
No worries!
I think we got an extra life somehow, so it's like we didn't even die.
There we go.
Oh my god, now it's two of them!
Shoot.
Okay, at least got one of them.
Uh
-oh.
Die.
Please die.
That was really close.
I almost overcompensated too much on that too.
And we're back, baby!
With our regularly scheduled programming.
Last platform.
Unless it means...
No!
It's not there for sure.
Huh?
Theory crafting time.
Atlanta sucks!
You know what?
No wonder everybody died here!
Unless it...
Is it like a...
No, it wouldn't be like...
I can't...
I can't be above the door because...
Oh my god.
Oh!
That's a great theory.
Oh...
Oh, wow.
Ah!
Okay, can I get a hit number two?
Can I get a hit number two?
Have you tried under the bridge?
Is it actually an under door?
Oh!
My bad.
It's not an invisible door.
What?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Under the bridge?
Oh my god.
The last platform.
I don't know if I've fallen here before.
Have I fallen here?
Okay, it wasn't that.
Oh, oh, no!
Okay, come here bugs.
I need to know how many there are of you.
Nice!
Sometimes the RNG just works.
Sometimes RNG just...
helps out a little bit.
Maybe at this platform?
Here?
Wee!
I remember watching a dog play this.
Yeah!
It's already a month.
Here's so many more.
Thank you!
You're getting closer.
I wasn't sure I was going to make that.
Maybe it is just safer to duck from those guys.
Because they're inconsistent as well.
Like, how far apart they are sometimes.
Anka!
They say we're not a duck, we're vultures!
Poop!
And throw.
I don't think they're ducks.
I don't think they are either.
I do not think they're ducks at all.
52nd zone!
Please.
I want to see the 54th.
I think it was 54 after this?
Oh, I meant it.
Before I do that.
Beep!
Is it in between?
No.
All that just to die anyway.
Same method as the last level.
So I blow myself up?
Are you sure?
Maybe I blow myself up in the...
Hold on.
Like in this area?
Here?
Blow up!
Blow
up.
No, no.
Not to you!
I don't want to die to you!
Yeah!
How is someone from the 80s supposed to figure this out?
Back in the day, people actually used guidebooks.
And like strategy things.
There were some games that you could not beat unless you had an actual strategy book to use.
And took notes.
Yeah!
Okay.
Maybe.
Oh.
But I'm not even like dying to my own...
Oh!
I take it back.
I am dying to my own thing.
Ow!
Oh!
Alright, go down bug.
Ow!
To a specific spot.
But before I wasn't even dying to my own bombs.
So I also have to specifically die.
I won't know what the spot is.
Unless I die on the spot.
Oh, that's the most frustrating part about it.
Okay.
Skill issue.
Just die better.
Why aren't you...
Why aren't you dying, idiot?
Okay.
Do you have a game genie?
No, I never had a game genie.
Oops.
Anyway.
Wait.
Oh my god!
That guy came from the water!
Nasty!
Oh!
I did it again.
I did this last time too.
To be fair, you're so bad at it.
You came back twice.
Yeah!
Let's see your play through Emmanuel.
Huh?
Yeah!
It's just finding the door.
Oh!
I tried falling down the hole in the bridge.
I think I'll just die.
I don't think I'll go anywhere.
Yeah!
I think I'll just die.
Oh my god.
Run!
Wait.
There we go.
So what?
Maybe I do die here.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let's try every corner of this bridge.
Oh no.
Oh no no no.
Okay.
This is a platform.
Oh wow.
There's a lot of guys here.
Okay.
Let's go up.
And up.
Pshew!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Duck.
Actually I'm gonna go up.
Oh these guys stick to the ceiling!
Oh no.
No.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
Door!
Wait.
But is this THE door?
93rd!
Uh oh.
I think I have to blow myself up here.
No.
I do not.
Oh my god.
I almost ruined it.
96th!
Mommy!
Die.
Oh no.
Mommy.
Mommy real.
Die, mommy.
Oh.
Mommy real, mommy real!
I don't know what I just got, but.
Okay.
Mommy!
These guys are so cute!
Sorry.
Mommy.
Just an enemy rush?
I guess so.
I should've...
My bad.
Oh well.
Please.
I feel like I'm gonna run out of time.
Oh, we're almost out of the tunnel.
We're almost out of the tunnel!
We're almost out!
Okay.
Alright.
I probably didn't need to do that.
But I was nervous, okay?
Don't risk it.
Don't... 98!
Don't risk it!
What is that?
Oh my gosh.
What is it though?
Where do I go here?
Okay, here?
Nice.
Here?
Okay...
I'm not quite sure how this...
I see stuff over there, but I can't see anything.
The momentum!
Oh god, this stage.
Is it like an invisible floor or something?
No...
Okay.
What do you mean a graphical error?
Don't overthink it!
Wait, so do I go to... which...
It's the treasure chest wraparound.
Oh, okay, okay.
You can just...
You can jump.
Oh, there's not anything on the right side.
Oh, shoot.
No way.
Am I trapped in here?
I see.
Oh my god, that was so close.
That was so close.
Hiyup!
Okay.
Slow and steady.
Don't fall, don't fall!
Nice!
Okay.
Um...
Oh!
Wait, hello?
Okay, there we go.
Oh!
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
Just one more, mommy.
I hope I'm going the right way.
Oh, no!
They're coming from this way too!
Okay, okay.
Run, run, run.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
It would have been really sad if I had died to that bat.
I can't tell if I can jump over these guys or not.
But I'm not going to risk it.
It's a lot of mummies.
It's so many mummies!
Get out of here!
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no!
Go away, mummy!
I hope I don't even know if I'm going the right way.
I don't even know if I'm going the right way.
Okay.
All right.
Onwards.
Ever.
Atlantis, no nazzle!
Atlantis, your nazzle will be solved by my hands and my brain.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'm going to run out of time.
Okay.
I think I have to risk it.
I have to risk it.
Oh my god.
You know what?
It's fine.
I ran out of time anyway.
Is your rage meter still at zero?
Zero percent?
Yeah, actually, I'm feeling not so bad.
Oh my god.
Poop bat!
Sometimes they're like glitching on the sides and it's freaking me out.
Where's all the mummies at?
What the hell is this?
Where are all the mummies at?
Yippee!
Oh, there they are.
That looks suspicious.
Where?
Oh my god, oh my god!
Wait, please!
Wait,
what's that door up there?
Yikes, okay.
Oh my god, the timing is... oh my god.
You have to be speed, Minto.
What if I just jump over it?
I only have two lives left.
Can you duck and bomb?
We'll see.
Oh my god, if I bomb, I sit up so I get hit!
Oh my god, no way.
Okay, hold on.
He shoots both ways!
Is that even possible to do?
I don't even think that's possible.
How am I supposed to jump and duck at the same time?
It is?
It's possible?
Yes, but it's hard.
Oh my god, even the AI dies on level 10.
This room is insanely precise to do without a power-up.
Code only did it, but it took many attempts to memorize.
Okay.
So now we have two options here.
Now we have two options here.
We can either...
Where's my strategy guide?
We can either go that route...
Which...
Now that I know how to get past 52nd...
It's not so bad.
It's not so bad getting past it and getting to the rest of it.
It would be the 100th that would be the most difficult.
But...
There's also this invincibility route.
But that also involves going through 8.
Which isn't...
In theory, I guess, so bad.
But 10!
10 is where we would really struggle, I think.
I say we.
It's really just me.
You'll get better at 8 and 10?
You think so?
10 was the trees and the clouds?
Yeah.
10 was the trees and the clouds.
And then I don't even know what's beyond there.
But it's the invincibility route.
So...
I'm assuming...
The star...
Makes us invincible.
Against enemies.
I'll make a poll.
Which route...
Which seat should I take?
Should we take?
Route...
10.
Actually, I'll say...
Route...
Invinci...
Route 10.
Route 100.
I guess that's it.
I guess those are our most difficult ones.
Nagoya.
No!
Harem route.
I wish.
I don't mind trying 10 a couple more times.
But like...
How long of a route...
How long is it?
You know?
I'm scared.
Why is it 50-50?
What's wrong with you guys?
Which path leads to Akihabara?
I don't know.
The route is a 10, but it's impossible.
Route 100 is winning.
Are there two different level 100?
I don't know, actually.
I have no idea.
What is this level even?
There's so much of this game that I feel like...
Look!
Invinci!
88.
We also get a star.
There's so much of this game that we're skipping over.
But you know what?
Oh!
My bad.
The dark zone.
Wait.
I'm trying to...
What is the dark zone?
Ah!
Stop it!
I'm trying to read.
Dark zone and freeze zone.
Interesting.
Zone.
That is dark.
55%...
56% on route 100.
This is killing me.
I'm not even watching the screen.
But just hearing the game start and then he jumps and immediately dies is kind of sending me.
All right.
The mystery adventure starts.
Oh!
I had to jump over that though.
I just got the timing wrong.
Sunsoft started doing stuff again and I hope they come back to this game.
Wow.
What are you?
A masochist?
I don't know.
Though it's kind of interesting seeing that it's like not...
Like you can...
I can only play this in the JP side, you know?
So...
Okay.
Oops.
Wrong way.
Okay.
Let's get some points so we can...
I think you get more health.
Yeah.
We're back to seven.
So awesome.
Okay.
Oh!
Um...
Okay.
My game...
Glitched for a second.
And now we know where to go.
So I'm not so scared.
Just a little scared.
Uh...
Oh!
No!
Yippee!
Oh!
I went...
I'm so curious what those chests are.
Oh!
Okay.
I remember this one.
Uh...
Oh!
Don't...
Don't poop on me.
I can't tell if I'm killing anything or...
Hoopa-pa-pa-pa-pa.
Oh!
I don't know how I live.
I don't know how I...
How I live.
I don't know how I live.
Okay.
Oh!
Sheesh!
Okay.
And here we blow up.
Easy peasy.
What was this one again?
Oh!
Mommy!
Okay.
Mommy time.
This one we just keep running.
Mommy!
Have you ever played La Mulana?
Oh my gosh.
I need to pay attention.
It sounds familiar, but I've never played it before.
Maybe if I saw it, I would know.
Oh, cute!
There was like another game that I'm... Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god, wait.
What?
Are you kidding me?
Since when could you throw fireballs?
Since when could you throw fireballs at me?
He just pulled out a gun.
Yo!
Messed up!
He said call an ambulance.
Not for me.
Can you imagine if you couldn't move while the bomb was deployed too?
How much more difficult can we make this game?
There's a second version of mummies with ranged attacks.
And they look the exact same!
There's no distinction between them!
Before, I think I just was able to run past him, so I didn't even pay him any...
I think he was in a different spot before, so I didn't have to pay him any mind.
Uh oh.
I think the less creatures that are in the front, the more that are in the tube.
Okay, we didn't struggle before because the RNG was on our side, but...
I have faith we can get through this as well.
Even though we're wasting a little bit of lives.
I just have to get used to this new zombie fellow.
You know, our new mummy friend.
With his gun.
They only shoot fireballs if they hit a ledge.
They're like, hey, I'm not attacking you enough.
I really gotta... I really gotta get you good.
Are they supposed to be scorpions, or...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
There we go.
Earwigs.
Oh, gross!
Shoo.
Oh.
I wonder if it's worth getting that.
Oh!
I didn't know there were some guys up here.
Okay.
Slow and steady.
Why?
Sometimes he doesn't fall off the ledge.
Ow!
No, no, no, no, no.
I almost blew myself up.
Sometimes he doesn't walk off the ledge, and sometimes he's just like...
Sometimes he's just like, yup.
Oh.
I'm just gonna keep going.
What?
Why?
You saw last time I was able to do it by just kind of inching my way over.
What was the difference?
Walk the other direction?
I think when you're falling...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
There we go.
99th zone!
Okay.
Oh.
I can jump over these guys.
Just kidding.
How many lives do I have left?
Only five!
She's silly.
I love her.
Thank you for the donut.
Shoo.
Do you guys think that making sound effects enhances your gaming ability?
Because I believe it does.
For me.
Personally.
You know.
I believe it allows me to go further.
Beyond.
Help!
Nevermind.
I know.
Yeah.
I'm going this way.
Don't poop on me.
Oh!
If I had just waited...
Oh.
Wait.
They started throwing stuff.
Did you see that?
It would have actually been impossible to get there because...
Oh.
Not impossible.
We would have just had to kill them.
Now that I think about it.
But.
Also.
We would have had to kill them while ducking the whole time.
And I can't duck and shoot at the same time.
Why is my RH so bad this time!?
Ok.
I'm fine.
Let's go this way.
Oh!
I pressed the wrong button.
That was my fault.
I think I'm going to game over, yeah.
Seems you had really good RNG in this level previously.
It's true!
There was the second time that I went through and there was no zombies.
Battle cries definitely help enhance gameplay.
It's okay.
I don't think I want to go through zone 100.
You guys, I'm thinking about it.
I don't know if I want to go through zone 100.
Let's try zone 10 a little more.
I think I'm better with jumping now, right?
So...
I think...
I think I might be able to do it.
Wait, how do I... I go through 3.
And then I skip, right?
Is that what it was?
I can't remember actually.
We decided to go this way.
I go to 3 and then I go to...
Yes, because I got to get the boots at 6.
And this is fish.
Watch out for fish!
Watch out for fish.
And it's this one.
This one right there.
Yippee!
8th zone.
Oh no, I forgot about the 8th zone.
Oh 8th zone.
8th zone, please be kind to me.
I think this zone is what has made me better at the game.
Truly.
Just mastering...
I can't say that I've mastered it.
But getting past this zone is what I think made me better at the game.
Okay.
Oh my God.
I say as I die.
Oh, I hate Zone 8.
I hate Zone 8.
I hate it!
Why are there two of you?
I hate Zone 8.
Oh, that was a close one.
Oh, my bad.
I did not mean to... you know what?
That's fine.
And we're back here.
I remember my strats to... oh my gosh.
Good, good, good.
Okay, now we be careful here.
Okay.
We made it past the most difficult part for me.
Uh-oh.
I don't have a lot of time left though.
We made it!
Okay.
Alright.
And it was about here.
Yes.
I'm really having to like take such deep breaths with this level.
Okay.
Pixel.
Perfect precision.
It's not... you can't just jump off at Landis Man!
Please!
You can't just jump off!
Okay.
You can't just jump off, would you please?
No!
Why, John Atlantis?
I wish there was a... I was gonna say I wish there was a way that I could just practice the stage over and over again.
And I mean, technically, if I were to save state it, I could, but I'm not going to do that.
I'm going to do it proper.
Oh, my God.
Why did I not just jump to the next one?
I knew the next one would make it.
Okay.
And then if I don't get the star, I have to go back.
Which is even worse.
I have to go back.
I have to go all the way back and try and get it again.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
I made it somehow.
No!
Hmm.
The worst part is...
If I don't, if I, if I don't make it past it, or if I make it past this...
And then...
And then, there's an even harder level.
What do I do?
Because it'll make the last level easy because I'll have this invincibility.
But if there's something even worse than this...
It's these tiny guys, you know, in the middle.
Okay.
Just jump!
Oh, my
God.
Oh, my God.
That
was a close one.
Boop.
Okay.
Oh, my ear itches.
One thing I think is the most forgiving about this game...
Is, like, with specifically these guys...
You can shoot the bomb anywhere on the screen.
And they'll, like, duck, you know?
So, if I, like...
Have to do it...
Like, in front of them or beside them so that it doesn't hit me too...
It all works out.
There we go.
Okay.
Third zone!
Oh, God.
You have to street start from zone one.
Oh, yeah.
What do you think this was?
Okay.
Fish!
This one.
Sixth zone!
I missed the exit.
Please, game!
Eighth zone!
Eighth zone.
I said that about eighth zone, but maybe...
Maybe tenth zone will make me really good at this game, too.
I guess we'll have to see if I can ever clear it.
My God.
It seems like the most impossible feat ever.
Oh, okay.
We're here.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
You can't jump down from the third floor!
Whoa, that was close.
This one works fine.
Okay.
All right.
I got it.
There we go.
You have to go from the tippy top.
Just in case I fell through there.
Oh, my God.
I knew that was gonna happen.
I
knew that was gonna happen.
As soon as it happened.
As soon as I touched the wall, I was like, I'm gonna...
This damn bomb's gonna explode in my face.
Music.
Oh, God.
What the?
Where did you come from?
There's never been a... a crab here!
Nice.
Okay.
Please.
That was close.
But close still means we made it.
For now.
Okay.
Yes.
Tenth zone!
RNG is a cruel mistress.
Wait.
Oh!
I got the shoes, right?
Or am I... Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I don't know why.
Everything's starting to blend together.
Oh my god, no!
Wait.
Am I an idiot?
Yes.
Yes, you are, mate.
You're stupid!
Oh my god.
Okay.
You know what?
Grab that.
Maybe we'll get an extra life... from it.
Oh my god.
That was so close.
I
think this is where I typically... start.
No, no.
We did it!
And now I'm invincible!
I think.
Yeah!
I'm invincible!
Unless he's a friend.
Oh my gosh.
Imagine if, like, a mimic ate me.
You can jump at me all you want, bozo.
I can take it.
I can take a hint!
But I can't take a hint!
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
I almost tied to my bob, I think.
Okay.
See ya!
See ya, suckers!
My game is lagging for some reason.
Okay.
Oh, is this a maze?
Uh oh.
Okay, I'm just gonna keep going left.
Ignore.
Ignore chest.
Okay.
Oh gosh, it's a maze.
Oh, with time not on our side.
Slug.
Just keep going left.
Oh, darn it.
Again.
Just keep going left.
Keep.
Okay.
Treasure.
16th zone!
What are these?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Being invincible is awesome!
Okay, I can't.
Ignore it.
I wonder if this place has a hidden...
door or not.
That's my biggest worry is losing a life because I'm just walking and walking and I'm walking in circles like what?
What appears to be happening now?
Oh, never mind.
Five!
Oh!
She can tank the poop!
Hell yeah, I can tank the poop.
I can tank it!
Oh.
Okay.
I'm all... I'm... I'm covered in shit.
I'm... I'm...
I'm... That's why...
That's why they're leaving me alone because I'm so smelly right now.
Okay.
This game has gotten infinitely easier.
But where is the door?
Oh!
Speak and you shall receive.
Twenty-first zone!
Oh?
Wait.
Is this it?
Is this the one I'm supposed to go through?
Twenty-third zone?
I don't remember how many there were...
between.
I feel like I've...
I feel like I messed up.
Uh-oh.
Wait, what do I... what do I...
Oh, do I have to make that?
Okay.
Nice.
Just keep going.
I guess.
Yippee!
But I think if I die, I'll lose the star.
Okay.
Twenty-seventh zone?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
What is this?
What is this evil?
What are you?
Oh, my God!
Should I be checking the strategy guide?
I have no idea.
I mean, I'm still invincible, so...
Okay.
I'll just keep going for now.
Oh, my gosh.
Please!
Okay.
Oh,
gosh.
Nice.
Wiki How?
I'm gonna pause real quick.
I'm actually...
What?
What am I on?
Twenty...
Uh-oh.
I'm on the red path.
I was supposed to go to fourth.
Four!
I was supposed to go to four...
Now where am I?
I'm on the 23rd.
I'm on the blue path.
Oh my god, no.
What happened?
Where did the blue path... where did the four door go?
No, no, no...
No, no, no, no!
God, I'm gonna have to do ten...
Wait a second.
There's two choices here.
Which door... which door can I take?
29th zone.
Oh, sorry!
Sorry, sorry!
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
There was two doors.
Wait, actually now I wanna see where I am again.
Which door would that have gone to?
Wait, what am I at?
I have no idea anymore.
You know what?
Whatever.
We're just... this is... this is it.
This is it.
Can I... is this land?
Oh, okay.
It is land.
Look at these little skulls.
Oh, are you kidding me right now?
Are you kidding me right now?
I have to make that?
Okay, I made it.
Gosh.
I'm so good.
What the...
I'm taking the last door.
31st zone!
Oh, I got a lot of points.
Actually, I wonder if it does make me... it does want me to go back.
Probably.
Because...
It probably wants me to go back.
Because there were several doors.
So, you know what?
Let's just go back.
31st zone.
I probably have so many lives now.
But if I think I fall, I completely lose.
Oh my god.
I completely lose my invincibility.
Why are you...
Oh, it's getting stuck on these guys.
Stop.
I'm trying to open the second door.
42nd zone!
42nd
zone!
42nd zone!
I get trolled, I guess.
I don't even know if I can be mad.
Oh, oops.
I changed it.
I don't even know if I can be angry.
Are you mad, Mint?
I don't think so.
I think I'm really sad that I have to go through zone 10 again.
I think I'm just more sad that I have to go... How do I find...
Okay, we're gonna have to find door 4.
If I get past Zone... If I can get past Zone 10, I have to find the...
Oh my god.
Damn it.
Was this game made by Millenium Game Development?
The rage refuses to manifest.
Yeah.
Actually, I think I kinda wanna start over.
I think I wanna start over with all seven lives.
I wanna start over with all seven lives!
I wanna start over with all seven lives.
Punishment.
What's the goal in this game?
To discover the mystery of Atlantis.
Atlantis nonazo.
I cannot believe that...
There was three doors!
And one of them was just a black hole that stole all of my lives!
I can...
I mean, I can believe it.
I'm gonna skip over that so that I don't...
Accidentally...
Get an extra life.
Okay.
Alright.
Atlantis truly is a mysterious place.
Why did they build a door that leads to your death?
Oh my god, I'm playing.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Actually...
That was close.
Okay.
I wanted to grab that so we get a little extra bonus score for when we wanna get an extra life.
I don't remember how much you need for an extra life, but...
Every little bit helps, I think?
Oh my god.
Wait!
No, no, no.
I am going through here.
I forgot.
All the doors lead to your death, boss.
Where would it have gone if we hadn't gone through...
That one.
And I even opened the first one.
I'm such an idiot.
God.
And I got like a million points from the last door.
And of course I was so excited about getting through...
I mean, of course, who would have...
You know, I don't think anybody would have thought that that door lead to level 4.
Probably.
If they passed zone 10.
I imagine.
Third zone.
Okay.
Fish.
Wait.
It's this one.
Sorry.
I got a little confused.
Okay.
Please.
Eighth zone.
All right.
Here's where we start.
I think I'm gonna struggle.
That's okay though.
I am stronger.
I am not the same Mint I was.
Twenty.
Nay.
Thirty.
An hour ago.
I have learned.
I have grown.
I have nozzled.
Oh my...
Okay.
First of all, that didn't affect him.
Second of all, I am very happy that I didn't die.
But why did that not affect him?
Why did he not go into his little shell?
Oh.
Wait.
Actually, I want him to go.
There we go.
Okay.
Why?
He fears nothing.
Okay.
Here's this part.
We need you to go away.
Thank you.
And we need you to go away.
Thankus...
I really thought I had it.
Clutch bomb.
But I really thought I had it.
I thought so.
I thought I had it.
Thanx.
I do want to thank this game that testing my patience, giving me a new appreciation on AfterLive.
Thank you.
To whoever created this game... I hope you know that you have... there's a very special place in hell for you.
Oh my gosh, I'm so... I'm so scared of this part!
Oh my gosh, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, there we go, okay.
There we go, there we go, there we go, there we go.
Okay, alright.
Oh my gosh, am I gonna make it?
Do I have enough time?
Oh my god, I don't know, I don't know, I don't know.
Okay, oh my god.
Okay, we have six lives!
Not bad!
Okay...
In fact, I am gonna grab that.
Maybe get an extra life, I don't know if it does or not.
No!
That's fine.
Oh god!
Jump King no nazo.
There's a second door to the eighth stage, remember?
What about it?
Oh my god!
You can grab the star and go back.
Where did the... where did that stage lead to?
I actually don't remember.
No, that went to Nagoya, didn't it?
That went to Nagoya, didn't it?
Oh my god!
Ui!
Huy!
Where's the secret door?
Where's the other door?
Four.
I can't go anywhere else.
No, wait.
No, no, no, no, no.
Pause the game.
Does this lead to four?
Okay, I'm gonna check.
Well, it is four that we go to, that I need to go to.
Yes, ten to four.
Ten to four.
You're up soon.
Thanks, Amarvi!
She's grunting like that because she's actually jumping in her room as she plays.
This goes to twelve.
We don't have so much time, you guys.
Wait.
You might be wondering, what the hell?
What the heck are you doing, Minto?
I'm gonna go back.
Do I have to... I'm scared.
Do I have to bomb myself in front of the door?
Or somewhere?
Do I have to die to a bomb somewhere?
I don't think it's...
No, no, no!
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Okay, I have to go and bomb here.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Now, with precision.
Take it.
With precision.
Fourth zone!
Where am I?
Oh, I'm up here.
Okay.
Will the spikes kill me?
No.
Okay.
Jump!
Alright, now...
Hold on, sorry.
I don't mean to pause again.
I'm looking for... I'm looking for door...
I'm looking for door... twenty-five!
Twenty-five!
I wish these were labeled.
Hoy!
Seven?
Time to go back.
Leave me alone.
Leave me alone!
Seven.
7.
Okay, keep on searching.
Okay, it's gonna be around here somewhere.
Here!
Third!
Floor.
Is there anything over there?
If I jump...
Check to the right.
Fourth zone.
Okay.
Can I make this?
Actually, I don't know.
I don't think I can make this unless I...
Oh no, I have one more!
Wait!
This might be okay.
Wait.
No, it's not okay.
This is not okay.
I have one life left.
And no way to get down.
There we go.
I lost my invincibility.
I lost my...
Jax, thank you.
Are you winning, Mint?
Well, I mean...
We're closer to...
Okay, 1, 2, 3, 6, 8, 10, 4...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
On this route, we only have 5 more levels left.
So I think we're over halfway there.
And I can get past level 10 now, so...
I think that's...
That is a win in my book.
Quite honestly.
It's only been...
It's only been 4 hours.
We're fine.
I'm starting to get hungry though.
But I have some food that...
I can...
What?
I threw the bomb!
You...
This is where I should not be losing lives at.
Okay, I'm gonna start over.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna start over.
I'm gonna start over.
Just kill me.
Rage meter 0%.
Are you gonna die?
I'm gonna die!
I'm going to die!
Is the rage meter broken?
No, I don't think so.
Beep, beep, beep.
No!
I think I'm at rage...
5%.
Just because of that one snail.
Really grind my gears.
Cheers.
You can reset the game from the switch menu.
I'm trying to pretend I'm not on the switch.
I'm trying to be like...
Look at me playing Famicom game.
So just pretend you don't see the switch menu on the bottom.
Just pretend.
Mint game!
I'm gonna go get some food.
I'll be right back.
I'll be like a second because I don't have to heat it up.
It's just some cheese and crackers and stuff.
So I'll be right back.
I'm back.
We're gonna have a short...
We're gonna have a short inter...
mision.
A short...
short...
inter...
min...
tion.
So I can...
So I can eat.
So I'm gonna just turn this...
off.
So we don't have to listen to it.
And I got...
Oh my gosh.
I got some of my favorite cake last night.
So...
I am gonna eat some of that for...
for...
for energy.
And I have some chicken salad.
And some crackers.
I mean...
Not crackers.
I thought they were crackers.
It's...
It's a...
It's a bread.
And some cheese.
And some grapes.
Rage reducing cake.
It's my favorite cake ever.
It's so delicious.
But it's from a specific store.
So if I like ever move away...
I'll never be able to get it again.
You know?
It might be one of the only things keeping me here.
Nom nom.
Nom nom nom.
Maybe...
Actually...
I'm gonna turn on some music.
So I'm not just...
Eating.
Oh!
This is...
This song is called Lemon Cake.
How...
How fitting.
Oh my god.
It's loud though.
Yummy.
Okay.
Just a short little...
Five minute...
Five...
Five middle...
Five minute break.
For me to eat.
I can barely open this.
My hands are starting to shake.
Because of the caffeine.
And also...
It's hard to open things anyway.
When you're...
Go!
You know?
I'm proud of how much...
Progress I've made so far.
Especially with stage 10.
I was really thinking...
It would be impossible.
And I've done it twice now.
So all in all...
Good.
You've honestly made it pretty far into the game.
And like...
It's been four hours.
But we've tried different routes.
So...
Platforming pretty well.
Yippee!
You're accidentally taking wrong routes.
More explanations.
So that's nice.
Yeah!
Exactly!
Do you want to try another Famicom Rage?
Kusoge?
Try Transformers Convoy no Nazo.
I can't remember.
Is Cheetah Man...
A kusoge?
I don't know.
Or is it just silly?
Beep!
And this is also...
I want to play Ernest Evans too.
It's horrible.
Boop!
Uh-oh.
My music is on the other screen.
The one that's being occupied by the game.
So...
Okay.
I got it though.
I recommend Bugs Bunny Birthday Blowout for NES.
Oh!
So bad he couldn't even finish it.
Could continue the Game Center CX Greatest Hits and play Quest of Key sometime.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I would like to.
I think, you know, in the journey to become a better gamer, you must start at the basics.
And honestly, this feels like a good starting base, you know?
When something is so unfair and so...
So...
Um...
I guess unfair.
It's unfair.
Something is so unfair and so precise.
I think it's...
It makes you...
It hones your skill as a gamer.
Don't forget your skills as a gamer.
So, Mario next?
I don't like Mario.
I'm tired.
Pretty sure I played... I played original Mario before I graduated and I was... I think... did I use save states?
If anybody remembers.
I think I did.
You did?
I played it, yeah.
I don't remember if I...
Yeah.
You're pretty good.
Hand gesture.
Thank you!
Thanks for one month!
But um...
Oh
my god.
That chicken salad.
Oh my god.
The texture of it?
The texture of it did not hit.
Oh.
Oh, I thought I was gonna... Oh, I thought I was gonna throw up for real.
Okay, no more... no more chicken salad.
I thought I was gonna throw up for real just now.
Oh my god.
Eat the cheese!
Thank you!
Kiss!
Here's some cool story while you... while you listen.
I just finished Fallout 1, a very old CRPG game back in the day.
It was a rough experience, so since I just lost my progress yesterday, I had to play my older save.
It frustrated me though, but it's fine.
Congrats on... you finished it!
Congrats!
I um...
I have been watching... I think because of the Fallout show...
Um...
Hold on, I gotta restart the music.
Because of the show...
Um... I've seen a lot more videos about Fallout.
Like, creepiest, Fallout, Bunker...
And some of them are like...
Some of them have like... intrigued me enough to where I'm like, now I'm really interested in playing.
I don't know if I'll stream it though, but...
Fallout 1 is fantastic.
Oh yeah, the vaults!
That's what I meant.
That's what... yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're just like, this vault was creepy because it was an experiment to see how people reacted if this and this happened.
And I'm like, whoa!
Whoa!
I would love to watch you play Fallout.
I know nothing about it.
Except... only what I've heard from those videos.
You said you couldn't play single game without... single player game without chat though?
It's not that I can't.
It's just more fun.
I find that I enjoy the game more when I...
When I... um...
When I play with the chat and you guys...
Reacting and...
Us having fun together.
That's why I feel like, even with this, I'm not raging so much because I'm like...
Silly game.
I have some cheese left over.
Maybe...
Okay, I'm gonna have one bite of cake.
For motivation.
Open the cake.
Not a kusage but I think you'd get a kick out of Haunting Ground.
Daniella is a very amazing spooky maid!
Like me!
Since you asked about GameCube stuff too, PN03's Vanessa is also good.
Oh, thank you!
Oh, look at the Haunting Ground.
I think I've heard of that.
Um...
Oh my god, speaking of spooky maids.
At... at Disney...
At Tokyo Disney.
I don't know if it's American Disney too, but for the Haunted House ride...
They had, um...
They had Mickey Mouse ears...
That were...
I don't even actually know if they were just ears.
But they were, um...
The girls...
The girls at the Haunted Mansion...
That run the ride...
They're dressed up as, like, ghost maids.
And they're just so cute!
And they sold their headbands.
I don't know.
I hope...
I don't know if it was like...
If they sell it year round or...
If it was just a Halloween thing one year.
But I saw someone wearing it.
And...
It was so cute!
And I searched the park, but I couldn't find one.
But...
Oh my gosh, it's really cute!
I search...
I recommend...
Look up the Haunted House...
Haunted Mansion...
Maids...
At Tokyo Disney.
They're so cute!
They dress as the maids and butlers?
Oh, they do?
Might be the same then.
Okay.
I had one bite.
I'm having one other bite.
Wow.
It's so yummy.
Wait.
I should go put this in the fridge.
I'm gonna go put this back in the fridge.
So it doesn't...
Doesn't get warm and melt.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Just a little bit.
Also, I'm gonna get more water.
So...
I'll be right back.
One more time.
Sorry.
Sorry!!
Sorry!
Sorry.
I'm
back!
And I'm ready!
RANGE METER!
DECREASE!
Calculating...
CULATING...
PERCENT.
4 PERCENT!
3 PERCENT!
2 PERCENT!
K?
Nice, alrighty.
Are we ready?
Now we know how to get to level four and from there we don't know what we're doing but we will figure it out because we are super smart and we will get it right on the first first try and we won't get it wrong and we also won't die oh yeah take that take that yeah take that take that
is it weird to be having so much fun with this game And when it's supposed to be like a rage game.
Drop down, drop down.
There we go.
Better to be safe than sorry.
A little.
Maybe I have gone insane.
Maybe I've gone insane.
Fish!
Fish, f-f-f-fish.
It's a fish.
Fish.
Oh, it's a fish.
Fishy.
It's a fish.
But you've got fall.
You guys, I recently learned that there's...
Okay, so I always knew that I couldn't burp.
It's this one, right?
Yeah.
I always knew that I couldn't burp, but I recently learned that there's a thing for it.
It's called like...
I don't remember what it's called actually.
But...
I can't burp.
I can only...
I only make a weird sound in my throat.
It's really weird.
Sorry.
I thought about it because it just happened where my throat was like...
And I was like...
I learned that that's a thing.
I'm actually incapable of burping.
I've never burped once.
Maybe as a baby.
But...
I don't even...
I try.
People will be like...
Just...
I don't even know how to do it.
They're like, try.
And I'm like...
Oh my god.
I need to pay attention a little bit more.
Have you also ever tried screaming after you let all the air out of your body?
She's gonna pass out.
That was so unfair.
No!
I did everything!
Actually rubbed.
Oh my goodness.
Nice.
Was it because...
Where did I...
I actually don't know where I...
Took too long on, to be honest.
Everything is starting to like...
Blur together.
And it's just becoming muscle memory at this point.
Oh...
Oh!
Ahh!
I hate level 8.
I think I hate this level more than I hate 10.
Quite honestly.
Okay, we made it here.
I'm excited.
Oh.
Please leave.
Okay.
Zone 10!
Alright, guys.
We can do this.
We can do this!
That's not what I wanted to do, but that works.
Okay.
BGM that burns your brain.
There's like two soundtracks in this... two songs in this game.
But we're getting better.
We're getting better.
Nice.
No.
Oh.
Oh my god!
Oh my god...
Duh duh duh.
Hoi.
Yah.
Gah.
Hoi.
GAAAAH!
I hate level 10.
I do hate level 8 more than 10, though.
Hoi.
Ah.
I'm so good.
Though will I run out of time?
No.
Who knows.
I think I did that relatively quickly, though.
Okay.
I think I did that relatively...
Okay, so going to the third one is like ideal.
I wanted to see if I could do it for the second one.
I wanted to see...
Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
Please.
Mr. John Atlantis.
Please, Mr. John Atlantis.
Just use your feet.
Grab it with your toes.
There we go.
Okay.
Acquired.
Oh.
That was close.
Okay.
Cloud.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh.
I didn't think I was going to make that.
Yippee.
Wrong.
Oh.
Actually...
Wait.
I have to go through here first.
Do I have...
Oh.
I only have one life.
You guys.
Oh.
This is not good.
This is not looking very good for me.
Okay.
Fourth zone.
We're...
Okay.
Go this way instead.
Oh, no.
Okay.
I can make it.
I can make it with this.
Okay.
It's okay.
I know the secret for stage 10 now.
I know...
I know how to get through stage 10 now.
NES video games are proof that people used to need to jump more to get around in their daily life.
Yes.
This is historically accurate.
This is extremely historically accurate.
Oh my god.
Wait.
That was close.
Hey, get out of here.
Oh.
All right.
John Atlantis.
Claim your title as the one true Atlantis king.
Okay.
This goes to three.
Three.
We go to six.
Then...
Fish incoming.
We'll let this guy fall.
Fish.
Why is the fish from another direction?
I
thought the fish was going to be from another direction now.
I thought the fish was going to be another direction now.
We're out of time.
Noooo!
Fish incoming!
Let him drop.
I'm gonna start throwing them the opposite direction.
I came up with that in my brain.
I was like, wait a second, why am I throwing it towards them?
And then risking myself getting blown up if they stop.
Only four lives left.
Oh, this is so bad, you guys!
Please.
I need you.
Four lives left for level eight?
It's not good.
This is not looking good.
This is not looking good, you guys.
Once we get the star, it doesn't matter anyway.
It does matter if I can't jump either!
I tried throwing the bomb and...
Okay.
Redo time.
It's time to redo.
There's no way.
These are all practice runs.
Sometimes in life, we regress a little bit.
Or in afterlife.
Okay.
That's okay, that was only stage eight.
Eight out of 99, baby!
No worries here.
Eight out of 99.
Should do this game for GDQ.
I would love to participate in a GDQ one day.
But like...
Oh god.
Oh my god.
But I...
Me speedrunning anything?
I don't see that happening.
Maybe I could organize a VTubers games thing.
Oh my god, go go go!
I'm regressing right now.
Fish incoming!
Wait for the fish.
Let this guy die.
Fish incoming!
This one, right?
Yes.
Games done not so quick.
Ba da da bop ba da da bop ba da da bop!
Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da...
Oh my gosh.
Come on, jump.
Hoi!
Please.
I am pressing A.
Just uh...
You know.
Oh, this is a lag.
No, I'm just kidding.
Oh, please.
Okay.
Hoi.
Ah.
Huh.
Yah.
Okay.
I'll let this guy go.
Please.
Please, please.
I need the speed.
Huh.
Oh, gosh.
I thought I was gonna land in there.
First try, baby!
Yeah!
Ha.
I knew that was...
I knew.
I...
I knew at the moment that I had gone too far.
I knew it.
I knew.
That was...
I knew in the moment.
Do points matter?
I believe if you get enough points...
you get an extra life.
So...
It is good...
to have.
It's good to get them when you can.
Yes indeed.
There we go.
Yes.
Oh wait.
My bad.
Okay.
Alright.
Alrighty.
Okay.
F you chest.
Alright.
I think...
This is like...
the safest way to get down.
Okay.
It's the safest.
It's the actually safest way...
to get down.
No!
I didn't...
I didn't jump...
soon enough.
I lost the star!
I have to redo everything.
Oh yeah.
I'm gonna die here.
Maybe.
Actually I don't...
Are you coming over here or what?
Keep pushing forward.
You know what?
Maybe I can try...
Oops.
Dang it.
Maybe I can try level...
four...
without infinity to see...
um...
to see...
But we need infinity...
for the last level.
But we can see where the next...
where the door is.
You know what I mean?
Where the door is...
to the next part.
Maybe.
If we're good.
So let's at least try.
I don't know where the... duck.
Duck.
Oh
no!
Oh my god.
Gaming.
It's right here!
Oh god.
This part.
Um... hello?
I don't think this is possible.
Oh my gosh.
I made it.
Okay.
So it's just a few over.
As long as I can make the jump.
Oh duck.
Duck duck duck duck duck!
Oh my god.
Ah!
I jumped too...
late?
Oh... gosh.
Duck!
Wait.
I'm surprised...
I made that other part though.
Seriously.
There we go.
Okay.
Uh... duck.
Not duck.
Bat.
To...
Oh my gosh.
That was so close.
Quack.
What is this area?
30th zone?
I don't know where I'm supposed to be at.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let's check if this is correct.
It's not correct.
Wait.
Then I can't go back.
Okay.
Well now we know.
Because otherwise we wouldn't have known.
Right?
Right.
Learning is half the battle.
We wouldn't have known otherwise.
Oh my gosh.
Leave me alone.
Hello.
Let's explore a little bit.
Have I been here before?
Oh my gosh.
Look at all this...
Look at all this Atlantis imagery.
Including...
Very tall bust.
And...
Grave.
Yeah.
I'm glad all you fuckers died, man.
Atlantis no butthole more like it.
God.
Don't be so rude.
Hahaha.
Is that a fountain?
Oh.
It might be.
Actually.
Spicy mint.
Sorry.
I'm a little spicy right now.
It's okay.
Okay.
When we go over there.
Do not go through that door.
Because you won't be able to get out.
So.
We discovered another thing.
Rage meter update when?
I'm actually not raging at all.
I'm actually pretty okay.
Hahaha.
I thought I would be raging way more.
But I'm actually alright.
I think we...
Okay.
Nevermind.
Hahaha.
These damn crows.
Vultures.
Whatever they are.
Poop.
What annoys me the most is we...
There's no in between to get more points.
You know.
Between now and...
Getting to level 10.
So it's just...
Pure skill baby.
Pure skill.
I mean...
We did level 8.
One try.
I don't think we will again.
Hahaha.
And...
Level 10.
In like 3 tries.
Actually I don't remember.
It might have been 4.
Who cares.
Atlantis no unko.
So true.
Unchi everywhere.
FISH INCOMING!
F...
Let this guy die.
FISH INCOMING!
You were a little late there buddy.
I almost was proven...
I almost looked like a liar.
Atlantis no unko!
Oh I was like...
What is this one?
Oh my god.
Ba da da ba.
We game through there.
We game through that.
Okay here we go everybody.
I don't know why I deployed that.
But it's fine.
Just for safe measure.
How I lived?
I don't know.
But I lived Birch.
Wait for you to go.
Okay.
No!
Hoi!
I didn't...
That was just me not getting enough...
of a head start.
How many lives do I have left?
Five?
Actually not sure.
Okay.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
I didn't know if I was gonna make that.
I...
Please.
I need you to make jump...
longer strides serve.
I know your legs can handle it.
Any crab percent.
Remember
happy day.
I'm already wasted a few seconds man.
I mean I say seconds.
A few...
numbers.
I don't even know how fast it's going.
I knew I was gonna run into that guy.
I knew it.
Safe.
So glad you can throw things in the air.
I'm so glad you can throw things in the air.
Throw bombs in the air.
Or else I would have been...
done-zo.
Done-zo.
There's two of them.
Please.
Tell me 200.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please sir.
Okay.
Four lives.
In the tenth zone.
It might...
Might not be enough but...
We shall see.
This game is making me so out of breath.
Nice.
Don't jinx it though.
Let's go.
Any crap percentages.
Yes, Krabby.
Now I just need to not mess it up here.
Okay.
Nice-u.
Okay!
25th zone!
Let's go!
Okay.
Now we know it's not that door.
What does this do?
What does this give me?
I can't get it.
Don't go through that, though.
Don't go through that.
So much poop.
I know, right?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
I'm going to have to start blowing stuff up, I suppose.
Hoping for the best.
But...
Looks like a clock.
Does it slow down the time?
Because if so, I really need that right now.
I really need...
I wonder if I should just...
Okay.
Here?
Maybe...
Because this is where...
No...
Do I go up?
I think if I collect that clock, I go straight into that door.
Okay.
The clock slows down the timer to actual seconds.
Oh, that's so nice!
I won it!
Come on!
Please!
Unless it's like a... I have to blow up myself somewhere.
I'm afraid to blow up myself right here.
Blow up the right chest.
No...
Nothing.
I think I just already did that spot, but I don't think I did here.
Next to the chest.
Okay.
Let's go back through.
I thought that killed me for a second.
Whoo!
Okay.
Oh my god!
I was just... I was just like...
What the hell?
Okay.
Yippee!
41st zone!
Oh!
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Is this another... blow it up?
Wait...
Uh...
Uh-huh.
Let's open up that door.
Hmm...
Um...
Uh...
Trying to create Green Rave when...
Maybe if I bounce...
Oh, dang it.
I was gonna say if I bounce it...
How the hell?
Maybe I...
There we go.
94th zone!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
It's Brown Rave!
Oh god!
It's Brown Rave everybody!
Okay.
I thought this was the ice area and I was nervous for a second cause I thought that it would be slippery but it's not at all actually.
Oh my goodness.
It's Brown Rave!
Wait.
Where do I go from here?
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Did I go the wrong way?
Uh...
Shoot.
Hold on.
No.
There's nothing that way either.
Wait.
Huh?
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh.
Maybe next to this chest.
Uh...
Okay.
I guess not.
Uh...
Oh my god.
Please.
Actually, someone just tell me the answer so that I can get out of here because this is so awful!
Oh wait!
I think...
Wait.
I think I remember this one from the Game Center episode.
Oh no.
You guys, we might be here for a while.
No.
Ah!
Last time!
Oh shoot.
I didn't notice the time.
The rightmost ledge.
Yes.
I remember.
I remember now.
Oh no.
No.
I thought only if I fell I lost the star!
Oh my god.
Oh.
God.
And then we have to watch this terrible flashing.
Oh gosh.
Oh.
Why is it...
Why is there like a motion blur there?
Are you guys seeing that?
What the...
What is going on?
What's going on there?
Dang.
Oh, that's so frustrating.
Okay.
I know it's on that ledge.
I have to like jump down, place the bomb...
Oh.
Jump.
Kind of like how I was doing it before.
I know how to do it.
Actually, I'm curious though.
One second.
After 94...
97 and then 100.
You guys!
It's just two more after 94.
It's just two more.
And 100 will be super easy because we'll have the invincibility.
Like we've...
We've got this.
We got this.
Okay.
We're stuck.
We're so close.
We're so close actually.
Okay.
If I can make it there without losing any lives in a stupid way, then we might be able to do it.
100 is the victory lap if we can get there exactly because we'll have the invincibility.
But we've made such good progress.
Proud of us.
Oh.
Why has the timer got to be so cruel though?
The flow of time is so cruel.
It's a cruel mistress.
Trust in your instincts as a soldier.
As a gamer.
Yes, master!
Master Pallet!
Fish incoming!
Why are you a backwards fish?
Oh my gosh.
That was so close.
Sheesh.
Let these guys fall off the edge.
Fish incoming!
Fish...
Okay.
Sixth zone.
Oh.
I missed it.
Oh my god.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Whew.
Oh that was so close.
That was so close.
Alright, here we go.
Gaming...
Oh I'm not
gonna make it.
Oh I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it, you guys.
I made
it!
I made it!
Yippee!
I made
it!
Yippee!
Oh my god!
Oh god!
Okay, okay.
Fourth zone.
Don't mess it up, Minto.
I don't know why I waited for that guy to pass.
I was just being courteous to him, I guess.
Okay.
I'm gonna try and get through the poop rave as quickly as I possibly can.
You guys.
I wish I could grab this.
I really wish I could.
Oh my god!
Okay, poop rave.
Shield your eyes, please.
Shield your eyes.
Oh, sorry.
Actually, I thought the poop rave was right now.
My bad.
Okay.
Poop rave!
Everything jumping at once is really a lot.
It's a little overwhelming.
Okay.
Alright.
We were doing so well.
It's okay.
You saw how quickly we got here.
We got back here so quickly.
I just want to get out of this damn room.
It's so awful.
It's so awful in my eyes.
Okay.
We got there quickly, though.
Update the rage meter.
Poop rave percent.
The green was so much worse, though.
It actually was.
You are right.
It was way worse.
I was actually concerned.
I was like, oh my gosh.
And I hope... I really hope that...
Because I had no idea it was a thing.
I really hope that, like, I didn't cause anyone harm.
Like, if they were epileptic or something.
Oh my god.
I was actually legitimately...
worried.
Back from watching Shin Godzilla.
Nam was right.
It was good.
Have you still not won?
Shut up, JB!
Shut the hell up!
Shut up!
Have you still not won?
Are you winning, Minto?
We're really close.
I'll be honest.
We're actually so close, you guys.
We're actually so close.
We're actually so close!
I just timed the bomb wrong.
I've timed the bomb wrong.
I actually was really concerned.
I was like, maybe I shouldn't play this game today.
Because...
Exactly the reaction I wanted.
I was like, I wonder if I'm going to get legitimately, like, mad.
Because...
I'm a little sensitive this week.
So I was just like, uh-oh.
What if I actually, actually start to rage?
It's not fun for people watching.
But...
I'm okay!
You timed the jump wrong.
That's what I said!
It's ghost week.
The time of the...
Of...
It's time of every month where a ghost is more rageful.
Okay!
Alright, Poltergeist week!
FISH INCOMING!
Oh my gosh.
The things that I have to do to keep myself sane.
FISH INCOMING!
Okay.
Sixth zone!
Oh!
Oh my god!
What the?
What was that?
A secret door that I unlocked!
Did you guys see that?
There was another door!
I wonder where that went to.
Oh my gosh.
I thought...
I thought I was gonna run into them.
That's why I stopped moving.
Cause I was like...
Okay, I guess I'll die here.
I guess it's time for...
To...
DIE!
That was...
Clutch.
I'm like...
Gripping my controller so hard right now!
It's kind of insane.
I'm like...
Hey hey hey...
Heh heh heh heh...
Hoy.
Hoy!
Nyiii!
Nice.
Nice sssooooooo...
Oh!
My gosh.
Heheh!
I wonder if I should start grabbing that chest if I have extra time.
If it will be enough for me to like get...
Oh mah goood!
An extra life!
Uhh...
I was going to say something, but I'm not going to jinx this level.
I'm not going to jinx it.
I'm just not going to say anything.
I was going to say I'm so glad I've gotten better at this level.
Oh, man.
I'm throwing!
No.
I don't even know how many lives I have left.
I don't even know.
Not that many.
Not as many as I had at the beginning of the stage.
Why did I do that?
One!
I'm not mad.
I'm mostly just sad.
Okay.
It's okay.
Two!
Forgive me while I'm worried about your voice, the shrill screams you were making.
You're too adorable.
Why is me screaming adorable?
That was close.
That was too close for comfort.
I'm going to try and get the treasure down here.
I think I have enough time to get it.
There we go.
I love the sound of people suffering.
FISH INCOMING!
Oh, that was early.
FISH!
FISH INCOMING!
Please.
Okay.
There we go.
Eighth zone.
Let's go!
Wow, there's no guys over here today.
They're all crammed up there instead.
And then there.
Hoi-ya.
Sorry I get so quiet at this level.
I'm really concentrating.
It's only 13?
Messed up.
I thought I died real quick.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Okay!
I don't know why I'm getting the timing on this.
Or I'm not getting the timing on this, rather.
Like I'm getting it... I'm doing so poorly with the timing.
This game is really playing mind games on me!
It's really... It's really playing mind games on me!
Oh, guys!
Why?
Thank
goodness!
Okay.
What do we have?
Five lives?
Four?
Oh, shucks!
Nice number!
Spooky number!
Four...
And the fourth zone!
Okay.
Alright.
I hope you guys are just as invested as I am.
Okay.
Alright.
This one has the clock that I can possibly get.
What was it?
I think I went from this side.
No.
Nice!
Okay.
Alright.
Even though I know I'm invincible, the poop still... still psychs me out a little bit.
Okay.
What is that hitbox?
Oh, right now we're invincible, so...
Alright.
Poop rave time!
Time!
Okay.
Nine lives?!
Oh!
Oh my God!
Oh my god!
Um...
You guys?
I don't...
If I jump, nothing happens.
Okay, time for leap of faith!
Oh my god!
Look at me taking all these hits.
No way.
No way, no way, no way, no way!
What's over here?
Okay, nothing.
Congratulations!
Oh, is that it?
Oh my god, I can't believe we did the last level!
First try, no way!
Congratulations!
Why is the timer still going?
Can I leave?
I can!
Wait.
Wait, maybe there's another side.
Maybe there's the other side.
Why is the timer still going?
Congratulations!
No, there's no door over here.
Yeah, you can play the whole game again, but backwards!
Go...
Is that it?
You have to go backwards.
Oh, yeah.
I'm just in another...
I'm literally just in another...
No way.
Wait, there's actually...
There's not even an ending screen.
Congratulations!
Thank you for the...
Thank you!
Oh my god, 51 cards!
Thank you for the...
Thank you, super.
Cheese...
Hold on.
I want to
be a little taller than them.
Yippee!
We beat Atlantis no night zone.
Wait, if the timer runs out, do I get a game over?
I wonder.
We beat Atlantis no night zone...
Oh, in way less time than I expected it to.
Holy cow!
Way less time than I expected it to!
This didn't feel like an endurance at all!
I god-gamered my way through it!
Hold on, I can... one second...
Yippee!
Congratulations!
Thank you!
It was the grip!
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
This music is driving me crazy.
But I'm curious what happens when the timer goes out.
Congratulations everybody!
This is it!
Here it comes!
5, 4, 3, 2, 1!
No way!
It takes me back to the screen!
It just tells me, congratulations again!
No way!
Sorry, I'm trying to adjust myself.
Oh my god!
That is ridiculous.
Okay, get me out of here please.
Did it waste a life?
I don't actually know.
Did I waste a life doing that?
How do I get out of here?
Yeah, I did!
Yippee!
Who is this guy?
Why are you here?
Why does it look like you are sitting on the toilet?
What is this guy?
The mystery of Atlantis?
Was it the diamond I got?
Can you exit the room?
We can.
Oh my goodness.
He's the nozzle.
Nozzle, nozzle.
Nozzle.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Okay.
Do I still have...
Oh, I don't have invincibility anymore because I...
Because I died on the winning screen.
Okay, let's just waste all of our lives.
Wait, there's a door here.
What's in that door?
Now nobody can say you aren't a gamer.
Congratulations!
Thank you!
Uh-oh, he's gonna start shooting at me.
Yup.
Oh my god.
This is...
Why is this game so hard?
It's so obtuse rather.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to die, but I'm too good at this game.
Wait, I wanna see where this door went to.
Oh my god.
Thirty seconds zone and it's pink.
What's the S?
Oh, whoops, my bad.
We're in like a graveyard.
I don't know what that just did.
Scallies!
Oh my god, I should look at them jump.
That's so silly.
Why am I still playing this game?
What's wrong with me?
S equals spooky.
Wait, if I...
Can I go this way?
No, I can't.
Congratulations, you have completed a great game.
And proved the justice of our culture.
What are you talking about?
Oh!
I didn't even notice him.
Okay.
Mint better than Arino Kacho confirmed?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
How do I please?
I just wanna go to the home screen, honestly.
I really just wanna go to the home screen, please.
So I feel okay.
I cannot believe I beat this game.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I beat this game.
I always...
I thought that it would be...
That I would have...
Like it would take me like three streams to beat it.
But no, I beat it.
Don't ignore that part.
Ignore...
Don't look at that.
Don't look at the game over.
Congratulations.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Give me a second.
One second.
I gotta make us...
I gotta put everything up.
Hold on.
One second, you guys.
One second.
I gotta get the chat all ready.
Hold on.
Oh.
Wait.
No, no, no.
I'm ruining everything.
Pop out chat.
There we go.
Gotta get everything ready.
Here we go.
Oh, no.
You can still hear it.
Stop.
Wow.
One second.
Let me also...
My computer.
There we go.
I thought I was gonna be with you guys all day.
Oh, no.
I mean, I kinda was.
But, wow.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
The game is over.
Oh, my goodness.
I remember watching Korone beating this live and it is an honor and a privilege to see you doing it as well.
Congratulations.
God gave her Minto.
I actually kind of want to try the way she does it.
She did it because you guys said it was more difficult.
Kind of curious how much more difficult it is.
I mean, once you get the invincibility, it's just like a walk in the park.
But...
And I think I probably would have been stuck on the poop rave more if I hadn't remembered where the door was.
Not...
Actually, no.
I don't think.
I know I would have been stuck on the poop...
The poop rave more.
If I hadn't known where the door was.
So...
That leap of faith was clutch.
I can't believe...
I cannot believe that I did that last level in one shot.
In one...
I cannot believe.
Without invincibility, it takes forever?
Yeah, I can imagine.
But I'm curious.
Korone-san did the actual gamer way.
The actual gamer way.
The actual god gamer way.
Maybe I took the easy way.
But...
Ohowowow.
It was still...
It was still a time.
A time.
Oh, wow.
He's so loud.
Oh my goodness.
Sorry.
Goodness gracious.
Chuuu!
Thank you!
I guess the real Atlantis isn't Azuma.
This was the Vtuber we gaslit along the way.
It was hard either way, Minto.
Maybe.
Corrin, thanks!
Korone had to memorize the precise jump pattern to get through it.
I want to try.
Like I said, I like challenges.
And this was quite a challenge.
It's like those three numbers.
It's the order of statues you need to bomb to get the door that warps to the end.
So it is Nagoya.
7, 3, 8.
I bet.
Or I'm assuming.
Was there even a single mermaid in this game?
There was the fish people!
Yeah!
There were the fish people!
The fish people!
11 hours Sisyphus endurance win.
I don't know.
I prefer older Rage games to newer Rage games.
Because I feel like...
I mean, not to say that older games don't make them obtuse on purpose.
They are.
And they're still... you know.
Angel, thank you!
Still, thanks for the chill stream.
But I don't know.
Games that are made to be Rage games are different.
Yeah, I think so too.
Right?
Have you played Echo the Dolphin yet?
Oh my god!
I played that when I was a kid!
And it scarred me!
That game...
My sister had a...
A...
The Sega Genesis.
Actually, sorry.
It was the Sega Nomad.
Because the Genesis one is the console...
Or the...
Like the home version.
Right?
And the Nomad is the handheld.
We had the Nomad.
And...
We had...
We had the Jurassic Park game.
Sonic 1 and 2.
The Lion King game.
Which...
Maybe I should try the Lion King game.
That is...
Oh!
Actually...
Oh my gosh!
I think I can still play it.
I think there's still a way to play it.
I never got to play the Winnie the Pooh game.
Oh my gosh!
Takashi's castle.
Maybe.
The Lion King game is hard.
It's so hard!
Maybe I should play the Lion King game.
And the Winnie the Pooh baseball game.
And...
Yeah, but we had that.
Lion King.
Jurassic Park.
We had...
A box with the Tasmanian Devil game.
Which...
But...
The game was not in there luckily.
And...
We had Echo the Dolphin.
I don't think there was anything else that we had.
But I played a lot of Sonic.
And I played a lot of...
Lion King.
Actually, I played my good share of...
Of...
Of Echo and...
Jurassic Park 2.
And Jacob's thanks for the 10 gifted!
The M in Minto stands for Masochist.
Lion King Game Gear is some deep cussom.
Yeah, maybe we'll have to play some more...
Games like that.
The...
The true...
Challenge games.
Sorry, my brain is melted right now.
My brain is so jelly right now.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like all the adrenaline just kind of crashed.
I did it!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, Brick!
Thank you for the 15 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Grats on 200k by the way.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
It's not that easy...
It's about time we've moved on.
Well, I'm gonna do what I like to do.
But, really, It's actually pretty hard for me to like, This is the only one I've ever played the fer main game ever.
But in this world is so hard for me because of my jed HUD just lost in puples.
IL troubler was standing up there and she must be one of his most featured options Uh...
Tada.
I'm like opening and closing them like okay all right let's stretch stretch them out.
Wait a second.
I'm okay.
Everything's good.
It's just text.
Checking a text.
I'm meeting my... I'm seeing my mom tomorrow.
But I will be doing a patreon game tomorrow.
You don't have to leave just yet.
Minecraft?
I'm trying to... I'm still trying to find time to organize a collab so I can get a tour of the Vshojo Minecraft server.
But I'm still really scared of joining it.
It looks so intense with that many mods they have.
Tell your mom we're going to play Minecraft tomorrow.
We said hi.
I will.
Tomorrow is Mother's Day for I think a lot of people so.
Wildestuck thanks for the Tony gift.
Thank you.
You learn base Minecraft from nothing you'll learn mods too.
Okay.
I'm also nervous because there's like a lot of people on the server that I don't know.
So I'm like, shy.
But yeah.
I've seen their server mods.
It's so cool.
Hmm.
I have to.
I've seen a little bit of it.
But I think it's mostly like the crazy.
I already I already feel like I don't utilize the crafting to its potential and regular Minecraft.
So I'm like, oh gosh, when it's modded, I'm going to be like...
Dirt house.
Scary time.
Thank you!
Thanks for one month!
But yeah, next week will be a bit of a shorter week, actually.
But I have a collab with my beloved Ayami-sensei!
Let me check the date.
I believe it's on Tuesday.
I will be streaming on Monday because it is a short week.
I'll be streaming Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday.
And then I'll be off for a couple days.
Until the following Monday.
But I have a Tuesday collab with Ayami-sensei!
So...
Yeah!
Yeah, I'm so excited!
If you don't know Ayami-sensei, definitely go check out her Twitter.
Oh, wait, I can get that.
I can link that to you.
Oh, be careful, it's a little...
It's a little...
Maybe sexy.
But she was...
She's Meru-san's mama from Hololive.
So...
Yeah, and her art is so sexy and cute.
What's the collab?
You'll just have to see.
It's actually not really a game.
So...
I was mad when my Fallout 1 got corrupted.
Oh, I'm sorry!
Sorry!
I know, that would really frustrate me too.
My birthday's on Monday!
Can I get a happy birthday?
Toyroxy!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Toyroxy!
But I'll be streaming on your birthday.
One Monday.
Monday, Monday, Monday.
Yeah, so I'm sorry that next week will be a little bit...
A little bit shorter.
But...
Yeah.
Cool.
I think I'm gonna head out then.
I think I'm gonna...
I think I'm just gonna go.
I'm like...
Yeah.
I
think I'm gonna head out.
Rest my brain.
I think I'm gonna go rest my brain.
And play Bloons.
I think I'm gonna go play Bloons.
Yeah.
Thank you guys for cheering me on.
I wouldn't have been able to complete it without your help for sure.
So...
I really appreciate you guys encouraging me.
And...
Also...
Calling me out when I'm bad.
And also...
Helping me with some of the puzzles.
Thank you guys.
Little word.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
So yeah.
See you...
If I see you guys tomorrow for the Patreon games.
Then I'll see you tomorrow.
But if not...
I'll see you Monday.
And...
Yeah.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you guys.
Congratulations.
See you.
Bye bye.